i saw a tweet from seth macfarlane
earlier
he said that he was basically saying the
reason why we can't
reach the far right is because disney
said that the muppets were racist
and i'm like i mean i guess it's kind of
bad that disney is setting them up it's
a racist i have no idea what that has to
do with the far right however
like wouldn't they like that the muppets
are racist it doesn't seem to make a
whole lot of sense
and the other thing too is that seth
macfarlane i appreciate that he's called
out cancel culture he's
pretty much like brian griffin in his
own family guy show like an insufferable
liberal but uh he he does use family guy
to complain about cancel culture i gotta
say
family guy though is probably like the
most racist show on tv
like making overt racist jokes all the
time
and for some reason and i'm i'm not i'll
just say that like for some reason
the left doesn't go after it maybe it's
because seth macfarlane is staunchly
liberal
and anti-trump and pro-biden that he
gets a pass but that represents i guess
the problem of the double standard i
guess the big issue here we'll talk
about this all this different cultural
stuff is
the muppets are racist it's important
that you know this you shouldn't watch
them and if you do you should know that
you're a bad person
we'll talk about that and a bunch of
other things too uh look we got a bunch
of political news coca-cola
it was telling people not to to be less
white
i don't know exactly what they're trying
to imply like i don't know what does
that mean do you like
bronzer or something that's not okay
either no so i don't know what they want
people to do
but i guess in the curriculum they're
teaching people they were saying that
being white is also being arrogant and
ignorant at the same time so
sounds like they're racist we'll talk
about that we've got some other
political stuff
cuomo apparently is issuing mafioso like
threats to everybody now
as he burns down in flames over having
killed 13
000 people in nursing homes and everyone
is turning on him
the reports now that he's issuing
threats and people are saying it's like
gangster level stuff
look at that we're being joined today by
some random australian woman who for
some reason is in my studio sydney
watson
i love this can this be like a new thing
i get some like good intros but this is
probably my favorite
random australian woman yes random
australian woman tell me why are you
here
um because i'm i don't know why am i in
the us or why am i in your house why in
my house
look i think it's a really long story
basically i got on a plane and i was
like i'm gonna stalk and harass tim
that's what i want to do today yeah we
caught her we caught her outside hiding
under one of the cars with a few of the
cats
trying to just like spoon vegemite into
my mouth while i like screamed
no but you live in texas yeah i do i
live in texas i live in the us yeah
but you're also american right yeah i'm
a citizen i'm a dual citizen
for those that aren't familiar you're
actually a youtuber with a pretty big
channel yeah
did you want to just naturally introduce
moderate channels yeah so i mean i'm
an australian american conservative
libertarian-esque
political commentator that makes youtube
videos and complains on the internet a
whole lot hey excellent we can play on
the internet too yeah that's going to be
great
it's like my mo right on we'll do that
we got luke here he also complains on
the internet
yeah i could constructively criticize i
think is a more
fair term i mean it's crazy out there
they're going after the muppets i heard
that the coca-cola coming after the
muffins
the coca-cola white polar bear had an
identity crisis
today it's bad it's bad so uh i'm
following all of it i'm also tweeting
about it on twitter.com forward slash
luke we are change and if you want to
support me you could also support my
voluntary efforts on venmo and cash app
under luke we are changing because you
do i'm here so thanks so much for having
me
we got ian chillin crosslin in the house
what up dog
uh cindy i'm glad you're here from texas
because i want to hear about
what it's been like this last week do
you mean with the freezing cold weather
just being yeah no it was um it was
actually really really not pleasant it
wasn't my favorite experience in the
whole world
i didn't have power for power heating
and water really for about
two threeish days which i know sounds
completely you know some people be like
oh boohoo but
when it's minus 14 degrees celsius i
don't know what it is in your made up
numbers
but in celsius it was so cold that i
you know you're standing in your in your
own house and your hands are pink and
you can't feel them it was don't don't
fall don't give me that our our
fahrenheit says it makes perfect sense
boiling point boiling point is it 216.
212. 212. and freezing is 32. it makes
perfect sense
okay everything that we do starts and
ends with zero and hundreds
it's just very uniform you guys metric
time
is there is i didn't think so your
system makes no sense because you
selectively do numbers the way you get
from
celsius to fahrenheit is you add 18 and
then multiply by 1.8 is that right yeah
i don't know but i do know at minus 44
they become the same oh
yeah that's true that's actually true
because people were like basically um
hanging crap on me and they were saying
sydney you're a big crybaby because it
doesn't snow in australia i'm sorry
i have never experienced minus 14 degree
weather it's
i've nev never in my life except when
i've been in the u.s that's the only
time what was it like having no water
um it's it it's not the fact that we had
no water you just have to boil it
because they
turned off the electricity at the don't
quote me on this not the sewage
plants but the water distribution maybe
whatever it was i mean i'm not i'm not
an expert at that
chlorination but they yeah so apparently
all the water now had like
salmonella and e coli and yadda yadda
you have to boil all that but you can't
boil it because you've got no
electricity because nothing's gas
so i was it was great guys the roads
were super fun
to rabbits in your backyard i did i
lured them i was like come here come on
you can't eat
you can't sustain off of rabbit alone
because they have no fat
it's called rabbit starvation how do you
know that i was reading about
venezuela yeah and they were talking
about how people were trying to breed
rabbits for food because they reproduced
so quickly and they eat grass
but people actually start dying from it
actually i think that happened in
venezuela
the rabbit starvation yeah i think it
happened once no maybe i think in a
different country but that's like a big
thing to talk about people think you can
do it you can't
but i think it's interesting so wait are
you you were in like a big you're in a
big city
yeah i live in dallas like dallas fort
worth area yeah so like you're
it's it's it it's apocalyptic when
you're in a city and this stuff happens
because you can't go hunt no you can't
go to a river for water nope
you beg the government or you run huh
well it's and then like i think this is
a thing that people don't realize
because i had a couple of friends
who live in the uk who were in the cold
yet it's been super cold in the uk and
they're like sydney it's just a bit of
snow i get it like that's definitely a
perspective to have but you're you're in
a situation where you can't drive on the
roads because they're just covered in
snow
and ice because no one you know no no in
texas i thought everyone in texas had a
pickup truck
um they did horses
it was just crap you know everything was
closed down you i mean look when you go
into the supermarkets there's no food
people are panicked buying it was just a
complete mess i i wouldn't recommend it
was the vegan food yeah the vegan foods
was it available it went in yesterday
and yeah in the meat section there was
only vegan thinking
um you don't like bill gates's you know
food
oh well he's huge in the industry of
creating fake fake me
he invested a ton of it and now the
mainstream media is running great uh
puff pieces about how wonderful it is to
eat fake meat hey
hey i think the vegan food's good i mean
i buy it i just don't like it when they
call it chicken and when they call it
meat like honey no no no no no no it's
not cheap they call it like
chicken and like like racist
yeah careful now yeah and like uh what
do they call furky they don't call them
boneless they call them wangs w a
and yeah g z or whatever because you
can't legally call it chicken or
whatever
because it's not i'm sorry it's not
i love it when you go to like get a
burger and they'd be like oh it's you
know it's a vegan chicken burger and i'm
going
no it's not this is this is the
antithesis of that this is vegetables
meat and vegetables completely different
entities can we not
have you had the the uh the burgers
where they reintroduced the heme
i don't know what's up the heme is like
from the hemoglobin in your blood that
makes it red
so they extract it and introduce it into
these plant-based things and they taste
like
real meat animal meat animal meat i
guess i don't think it tastes like meat
ever
but would that be i think they're fine
yeah that's a good
i don't know yeah because it comes from
an animal i don't know if they derive
the heme from animals in that case
no i don't think so i think it's like i
don't think it is yeah it's really weird
anyway let's uh let's talk about the
muppets we also got sour patch let's
press on something
here in the corner listening to this fun
conversation i'm sarah patch let's push
buttons
let's just talk about the the muppets
being racist ladies and gentlemen
this is very important news yes the
muppets
are racist and i think it's important
you know this and i think it's hilarious
that disney is
is like basically burning down its own
ip
the muppet show disney adds content
warning over
negative stereotypes disney plus has
added a content warning beginning of 18
episodes of the muppet show which
started streaming on the platform on
friday
the program includes negative depictions
and or mistreatment of
people or cultures these stereotypes
were wrong then
and are wrong now the disclaimer has
been added to each of the episodes for
different reasons
including one where johnny cash sings in
front of the confederate flag
the confederacy was the group of
southern states as the bbc
writing this might do that fought to
keep slavery during the u.s civil war
and the flag is seen as a symbol of
racism by many disney's disclaimer added
rather than remove this content we want
to acknowledge its harmful impact
learn from it and spark conversations to
create a more inclusive future together
the advisory note comes after several
months of revisionism around films and
tv programs
which could be considered offensive by
the standards of today so in this
article
they have this really big image of the
what is it the siamese cats in lady and
the [ __ ]
and the crazy thing is like are they
trying to imply that these cats
like are stereotypically asian do you
guys know what the siamese cats look
like
no they're it's their drawings of cats
what about these cats faces am i
supposed to think is racist
their eyes are long and pointed is that
what they're trying to claim they're
cats
cats have pointy eyes or whatever are we
talking about the the one where they say
we are siamese if you please and it's
very like asiany in the way that they do
it
oh yeah maybe i'm just saying like it's
kind of
yeah because iron what's that from the
that's the truth yeah yeah yeah yeah and
well i mean the face is not so much but
it's the song that they sing right
that's probably what they're getting
upset about
because it's got the little music behind
it aren't they high on opium or
something is that like an opening
no dude so but here's here's the main
point right uh
seth macfarlane tweeted this might be
why we're having so much difficulty
getting through to the far right
and it says disney plus adds negative
depictions disclaimer to the muppet show
what is what does that mean seth
macfarlane can't we can't get through to
the far right
what is he trying to say by that by by
telling people that the muppet show is
racist
the far right won't listen to you
possibly
is seth macfarlane saying well i mean it
makes sense family guy
i was watching family guy the other day
and there's an episode where peter gets
a whip
he buys a whip i guess and then it shows
cleveland cleveland brown who's a black
character and he's sitting on his couch
and then you see peter pull up to the
front of his house which makes no sense
because peter lives across the street
for those who actually watch the show
and then he starts running towards the
house with the whip and then cleveland's
phone rings
and it's joe saying just want to warn
you cleveland that peter has a whip
and i think that matters to you based on
your ethnical his heritage
and then peter knocks on the door and
says
you know a delivery of grape soda
quarterly or something
and then uh cleveland brown says well
the risk is great but the upside's
certainly worth it then he like walks
over
the crazy thing about that is and and
don't get me wrong i clearly like
the show family guy is that cleveland
brown cleveland
they clearly were making a joke about
grape soda and black people and
cleveland brown
is played by a white guy so it's like
peter griffin's going to his house with
the whip it's just like all around the
show
definitely does tons of racist jokes but
the main point is
disney owns family guy disney owns
family guy guy okay listen they bought
them a long time ago years ago
if they're going to come out and say the
stereotypes were wrong for the muppets
back then you're putting out the shows
now what are you talking about
not only that tim but this is the same
disney that publicly thanked
the detention guards that were at the
detention center for the uyghur muslims
uh there's there's you know if you're
talking about prioritizing some issues
here
maybe you know not working with the
communist chinese on
detaining uyghur muslims and
congratulating them you know
it might be a bigger issue than some
siamese cats i would just say but that's
my opinion
but this is the muppets too yeah i mean
it's just it's just ridiculousness that
we're having these conversations
about things that absolutely have no
merit absolutely have no effect
absolutely
have no credence in any one existence on
this world but yet
here we are fighting it i mean when
there's literally
human slave labor there's organ
harvesting there's other things
happening in china that
we can't even mention that of course are
condoned or congratulated or or
disney approved by by disney i mean it's
i love it
disney fires gina carano because she
said don't vic
demon don't demonize your neighbors they
they claim
that muppets is racist and those
stereotypes were wrong then and they are
wrong now
family guy which is owned by disney is
just overtly making racist anti-semitic
and gay jokes all the time
and they thank the there's there's no
there's no uniformity in anything they
do
none of it makes sense which is why i
just don't understand why they care if
the muppets are racist or not you know
regarding
family guy i think it's seth's kind of
interesting because he's kind of like
chappelle he he talks
about his stuff is racial but it's not
racist he's not doesn't have like
ill intent when he does his work or he
doesn't seem to same with dave he can
paint himself white and act like a white
guy
making fun of white people but dave
chappelle is one of the most loving
humans
in the industry well it's like george
carlin you know he he did this whole bit
in the early 90s about
it's not the words it's the person
behind the words if someone's doing a
comedy bit like george collin actually
used all the racial slurs you can think
of on his show
he's not racist he was making a point
about racism through humor
if if disney is going to come out and
thank these concentration camp guards
claim muppets is racist and then like
what about all their other properties
too
is what i understand was it like one
employee at the muppets show who was
like oh we got to make sure everybody
knows as a racist and
had no power in other areas or what it's
probably because they're having all this
attention drawn on them now
uh regarding the gina carano thing
that's probably why they're doing all of
this it's like i don't know i don't
understand the purpose of retroactively
judging something
by today's standards i think that's
where this issue comes in i mean if you
think about it it's not
seth macfarlane also made american dad
did he not yeah and that's also on the
same level of
super offensive content which i mean
mind you i love american dad i think
it's funny i
and i and i love the humor and both of
those both i'm american dad and family
guy excuse me
but i think the problem is that disney i
think at this point because they are
getting so much heat right now from
everyone
on all sides they're probably just going
and just making these
really random unilateral decisions look
family guy is on 24 7. you could you
could turn the tv turn
is that still being made i'm pretty i'm
pretty sure yeah yeah
there's actually a funny joke you know
the orville that's another show that
seth mcfarland is doing
and there's a there's a joke in a family
episode
where it's just peter and chris griffin
sitting sitting in front of the tv
and the tv goes and now back to the
orville and then peter shoots the tv
like a bunch of times and then chris
goes wow dad you sure hate the orville
why do you hate the orville
and then it's some random guy's voice
not seth macfarlane he goes because
chris
the orville is making it difficult for
seth to complete the family guy shows
he's working on
something like that so anyway
uh family guys on 24 7. it's you turn on
the tv it's on some channel it's on
local tv show local local
channels it's on tbs on fxs fxx
it's on a cartoon network it's on fox
new episodes on hulu disney owns hulu
they're not going to give up all that
free cash
so i just don't understand maybe it's
more like a culture revolution thing
right
that's what i was saying like seth
macfarlane is super true you know
traditional liberal pro-biden and all
stuff so they give him a pass because he
benefits their their party
but they go to the muppets because the
muppets is the old that must be purged
or something
why is he making those jokes this is
what i don't understand if seth
macfarlane
is a liberal why is he making these
jokes in the first place
that's that's not that that's not their
mo this is not the sort of humor that
they come out with i think a lot of this
honestly it's just kabuki theater as far
as i'm concerned
yeah i don't believe for a second that
someone like that is a liberal i'm sorry
i just don't yeah i don't either i was
shocked when he started getting
political i just don't believe in
political politics seth macfarlane also
whistleblowed on on harvey weinstein way
before anyone even knew
as far as his predatory kind of attacks
and kevin spacey so
he spoke out on this very nasty industry
that's called hollywood
that's filled with predators and other
things that i can't even say on this
show because it's a family-friendly show
and because of the youtube censors but
there's people in hollywood that are
absolutely evil that's one way of
describing it
that seth has called out and and you
know let's let's be honest here
disney is a part of that larger kind of
hollywood institution that's
not known for having the best record i
mean there's a reason bob igor the
executive chairman of disney was pinned
by biden
to be the ambassador to china you know
there's a reason
these multinational corporations are so
tied in together especially with big
countries
that's why they did the the cats the
asian cats because it offended china
could be i know siam and china are the
same thing and it's not far to speculate
that because
china many times has influenced
hollywood and had them edit out specific
scenes
specific mentions even scripts china
rewrote scripts of u.s hollywood movies
because they founded offenses or they
didn't like it in top gun
they even edited out tom cruise's jacket
because it had
mention of a war game between the united
states and china
and and and tibet and and there was even
another mention of a war game between
the united states and china totally
edited out
totally destroyed it totally you know
made it out so
when we have china dictating what
americans could see
in hollywood that should worry everyone
on a larger scale than just
oh look at siamese cats look uh muppets
here you know
it's ridiculous it's absolutely
ridiculous if we're gonna get into
cleaning hollywood and making sure it's
it's it's going to be a good industry
you're going to have to do some deep
cleaning on some raw and nasty
disgusting some would even say satanic
individuals
i'm optimistic on a lot of political
stuff a little bit like i was talking
about this on my
my main channel earlier just that it
seems like
the the establishment political machine
in this country has a serious problem
with
the best they could muster to stop trump
and bernie sanders is joe biden
like what are they going to do in 2024
they got nobody left the populist left
is growing the populist right ain't
going nowhere trump says i'm coming
so that makes me optimistic that not for
either of those parties necessarily but
that the establishment machine is is on
the ropes and struggling
but then i gotta tell you i'm really
pessimistic when i hear this stuff like
if seth macfarlane check it out he did
call out weinstein he was on he was on
an awards show or something like that
where what
he said something about it he just like
said it online he made side
jokes about him being no no a predator
and abusing children and then also on
this show
mentioned it uh on family guys yeah they
mentioned it several times and kevin
spacey but no there was like an award
ceremony or something where seth
macfarlane like basically said it
and he's also interestingly seth
macfarlane knows a ton of secrets about
hollywood
they he he called out weinstein he
called that kevin spacey and
they also called out uh bruce
bruce bruce jenner transition to caitlyn
jenner in 2009
and then they later were like look see
but it's because seth macfarlane they
act like oh no he got it right
no seth macfarlane knows all of this
hollywood stuff he leaked some of it
the crazy thing is if that's the best
hollywood has in terms of like actually
calling it out
is seth macfarlane sometimes putting a
joke out there because he knows it's
happening but when did seth mcfarlane
come out and say
ladies and gentlemen i have a very
important announcement to make harvey
weinstein is doing these horrible things
so he made a joke about it but kevin
spacey is doing these horrible things no
it's stewie running through the mall
making a joke about it but this is the
thing seth
made a joke about something that people
in hollywood knew for over 30 years
for 30 years they knew that there was
this monster weinstein
connected to of course the clintons
bankrolling a lot of the democrats
tightly connected to all the ruling
elites and upper establishments
and they knew he was hurting people for
over 30
years in unspeakable ways ways we can't
even mention on this youtube channel
and yet the only thing that happened was
seth just made some snide jokes about it
i mean it's disgusting
to even think about it this way yeah but
what's the option though is it what he
says something and then what
like he actually comes out and says hey
guys this is actually happening what if
no one's prepared to
attack him that's how bill cosby went
down it was it was a comedian
that took down bill cosby uh hannibal
burris that made jokes about it and he
was like guys this is not a joke
everyone was laughing thinking he was
joking about bill cosby but that's
literally it literally took a comedian
to bring down bill cosby another
horrible person within the entertainment
hollywood industry that again
sells their soul to the highest bidder
who has the most amount of money usually
china
uh sorry go ahead no no no no it's i
just i get what you're saying but i
don't think that bill cosby and harvey
weinstein are on the same level
in the sense of power control and all
that sort of stuff not that i'm
obviously a hollywood executive that
knows the ins and outs of all of it but
i would argue that
weinstein probably wields a lot more
power than say
you know definitely yeah any real both
they're both huge yeah
you know in terms of how they manipulate
but this is the thing in the in the
letter of the law in the united states
if you know a crime is happening and you
don't do anything about it you're an
accessory to that no that's not
necessarily true
well it depends on on the circumstances
and the situations and there's many
variables we could entertain here but
when you know
someone is do i mean like if it was
happening in his
studios and his like nypd literally ran
investigations when they had undercover
operatives
be abused by weinstein and they still
didn't do nothing
so so the nypd literally had audio tapes
of weinstein abusing a woman that was
working undercover for the nypd
and the nypd stand on it why why
uh he's connected to the clintons that's
one speculation but he's a very powerful
connected person this is what i'm saying
why would someone call him out if he
thinks that oh you know what i don't
want to end up as you know part of like
the clinton's uh
death tally like like i mean i don't
know how many people believe in all the
conspiratorial stuff surrounding them
but like why would you call it out if
you're gonna get
that in itself the whole the whole
harvey weinstein story is a conspiracy
within itself
and you have a choice you know something
they were covering it up yeah they were
actively covering up so if you know
something's wrong you have a choice
either allow it to happen or speak out
against it and maybe something will
happen maybe something won't happen but
the right thing to do
is always speak out against someone
that's a monster
and has been described as a monster that
has done unspeakable things that are
absolutely disgusting
and these are the people that are
protected within the industry that's now
lecturing us about what's appropriate
and not appropriate for us to see i mean
i'm just sick of it i'm just absolutely
sick of it because
it's not just the dem of vipers it's a
dem of
of child abusing let's be honest here uh
individuals who don't give a damn about
anyone and don't play by the same rules
as
everyone else will be specific that was
uh was it corey
haim or feldman corey feldman
they called out these like i'm not going
to name these some of these individuals
because
but uh it's not just him there's a lot
of celebrities i don't know they were
calling out
the oh right right they were calling up
the abusers themselves
and a lot of these guys end up finally
getting caught but it takes it's crazy
that you have these people these
whistleblowers and nothing happens
because these people these powerful
people in industry the industry
is selling sex that's when that's what
they'll tell you if you're in that
industry to your face
as your manager they'll say you're very
sexy we want to sell your sex
it's crazy your own manager man but i'll
tell you this
luke in order to call them out
people would need spines it's not a
common thing these days man
we're a wealthy nation and you look at
the nba you look at these people who are
just like hey china tell me whatever you
want because you've got money
you look at all these professors that
are getting busted for spying for china
then you look at you know like you
mentioned bob was it bob iger
i think yeah bobby biden wanted him to
be the ambassador to china is that
happening
uh we don't know yet i haven't seen any
updates on that yet but he pinned him as
the guy he wanted in there the
washington post surprisingly wrote an
article about how that's a bad idea i
was surprised by that
really obviously it's a very bad idea
but surprised to see it in the
washington post but
i haven't heard any updates about that i
think the position is still up and
hasn't been decided
yeah well let's let's let's talk about
the next uh ultra welch story here so uh
this is something that's been going
viral quite a bit
we got this from newsweek coca-cola
facing backlash says
be less white learning plan was about
workplace
inclusion that's the gist of the story
coca-cola is facing a mounting backlash
from conservatives
online that's what i really love about
how they frame this conservatives are
upset
ian are you a conservative well not not
really sometimes
do you think it's absurd that coca-cola
told his employees to be less white yeah
it's ridiculous
so newsweek you need to correct your
story it's not concern it's not just
conditions it actually says that
be less white try to be less white
that's ridiculous if i heard that i was
okay i'd be like darken my skin
like with a crayon that's that's that's
that's what i was saying like first like
i thought
you know like putting on bronzer and
stuff is racist it's literally a slide
that says try to be less white and the
way that
they they describe white is oppressive
arrogant and ignorant now if you said be
less oppressive arrogant and ignorant
that's all you know
no they're saying if you're white you
are bringing you are
oppressive arrogant and ignorant and i i
have to point out
um you know luke and i are both not
white yep oh no i'm sorry i'm sorry
that's wrong i'm double endless you're
you're like triple white no no no no no
not anymore not anymore according to who
the protesters in new york so the asians
were getting attacked
and they said march against white
nationalism and
that proves that asians are now
minorities again
oh but lucas slavic and according to the
coalition of people of
the coalition of communities i'm looking
it up right now so i can get my card i'm
getting my privilege card ready
there's an organization called the it's
called the coalition of communities of
color and they say slavic people are not
white
so for luke here who's literally got you
know what
what color is your hair look you say
strawberry blonde brown yeah yeah
strawberry blue dirty blonde blue eyes
white skin
big nose
[Laughter]
you're not white that that so try be
more like luke apparently coke is saying
yeah i don't understand this so you're
not considered white i was
i was born in poland so being born in
poland i'm a slavic
individual victims of communists i think
you're literally like
taylor than i am and i'm paying you i
make an observation like this
i am pink okay no you're a beige beige
basically
yeah okay this is what they're trying to
say though they're saying it's like
politically white
well this is a thing they make this
distinction this is the weirdest thing
about liberals today i just this stuff
kills me
they make this distinction between white
people and whiteness all the time as if
it somehow makes what they're saying
less racist
like it's this thing that they're like
you know what i mean like on a
fundamental level being a white person
is
okay but having a whiteness this
internalized thing that
you can have as just any person not okay
and it's like
yep all right cool makes sense it's it's
it's so insidious how they
they tie negative traits towards the
idea of being white
and then when you call them up for
racist they go oh no no we don't mean
your race
we mean it's just a word and you're like
no but if no one understands that you're
literally talking about race
my favorite thing with the story there's
a couple articles one of them
said it said coca-cola is accused of
reverse racism
for saying try to be less white i
haven't heard anybody say that's reverse
racist
everyone's just saying it's literally
racist another thing that's really
important to kind of point out here you
brought up the rally that happened in
new york city where hundreds of people
came out against
the rally against white nationalism for
noel quintano
noel contano was a filipino man that was
slashed across the face
beat up brutally not by a white guy
and it was a people were saying this was
a racially motivated
motivated attack it's all because of
white nationalism the guy who attacked
him wasn't white
what was he was he black yeah salmon
same in san francisco there's another
uh you know report of a hate crime and
there's another call for a rally against
white nationalism and again
the victim was asian and the perpetrator
was
not white this is this is this yeah this
is the biggest problem i have with it
first i i just need to clarify so i'm uh
i'm once again not white
is that what's happening here well
you're like you're like you know
you have a lot of privilege so you're
getting kicked out of universities uh
that's true so because you're too smart
yeah yeah yeah
so so the problem i have is these
well-to-do liberal progressive types
are tar are focusing on some racial
ideology that
literally nothing to do with these
crimes making it harder for us to
actually have activism around these
crimes
i don't care if the perpetrator was
white or black or asian or latino
i care that the crime that was committed
was illegal and someone got hurt
so how about we rally against violence
we rally against
racially motivated violence they make it
about white nationalism
and then there's no real conversation
about what's driving the racism in these
communities
the problem is if they acknowledge that
guess what black people can be racist
asian people asian people are really
racist particularly in asia i i'm not
super you know i know a lot a lot of
american asian people as well who are
pretty good because americans
we grow up in this culture we tend to do
a better job but my friends
and people i know who have come from
asian countries
they tend to be pretty racist right
anybody of any race can be racist have
prejudicial views
and view others as superior or inferior
it is rampant in southeast asia no joke
and if we can't get acknowledge that
because these well-to-do white
progressives
are obsessed with themselves and they
think somehow white is
superior or privileged like i'm sorry
man that is
leftist white supremacy that this this
idea that
their race is is paramount and
privileged above all others and that no
matter what happens no matter who
commits the crime
it's not the fault of the individual
commit the crime
it's white like these people really hold
themselves
to such a sting that no matter it's it's
remarkable no matter who commits the
crime they're like well actually
it's all about white people i'm like
dude you're racist
that's not true man and actually you
know
traveling the world whether it was asia
africa latin america
you realize that holy cow the world's
really racist
and i'll just be honest here you know
i'm not a big nationalist at all i don't
i don't like governments at all but
the united states honestly is one of the
least racist places that i've
you know seen and and was able to
observe it is the least racist place
i've ever been to
yeah same no joke you travel to africa
you travel to asia you travel to latin
america your eyes will
open up into the reality of the world
sweden sweden is more was more racist
than the united states when i went there
it was shockingly racist but maybe
racist isn't necessarily the
right word xenophobic is probably a
better word for it and i know that word
gets thrown around a lot by progressives
in this country but no let me explain
we interviewed this woman who was
american who spoke swedish
got married to a swede moved to sweden
and she couldn't get a job
and she said it's because nobody wants
to hire someone with an accent
so it wasn't even about the race it was
about you're not swedish
so it's super nationalistic in a sense
and what i discovered especially in
sweden especially from many minorities
who are working and trying to end the
stuff they would say like
swedes very much like to pretend that
they're not racist
but they are super racist so what
they'll do is they'll be like we're
gonna help all these poor minorities
and then put them all into like some
community with limited resources and do
nothing for them and watch it fester and
then just claim to everybody how not
racist they are
super racist the people pretending not
to be racist are usually the biggest
racist
same with uh homophobes the biggest
homophobes are usually
the biggest guys who are in the closet
let's just be honest what was up with
all those republicans
who were like super anti-gay but then
turned out to be gay yeah that that uh
republican who was caught in the
bathroom
all right all right trying to solicit
from an undercover
police officer activity i'm family
friendly don't worry tim i'm
gonna be very family friendly here
another thing to really kind of consider
here is that
you know a lot of people are attributing
you know white nationalism to
you know different people of race you
know beating each other up but
this is happening in new york city this
is happening in san francisco where
we're seeing these rallies and we're
seeing these kind of alleged hate crimes
but we have to understand
crime is going up dramatically in these
places regardless of race it's becoming
more of a violent
more of a criminal place where even a
two-year-old got punched in the head by
a panhandler
in a new york city subway just recently
there was other footage of a guy beating
another one with a baseball bat brutally
the amount of violence that is
overtaking new york city
is really reaching proportions that are
unlivable for many people
it's one of the reasons i left i'm never
going to be coming back there ever again
and this is the city that i grew up in
this is the city that i was raised in
and it's even coming back to a place
where when i first came into it it was
extremely violent extremely
somewhere we don't want to be so let's
we'll bring it back to this coca-cola
thing where they're telling people to be
less white
this weird try to be less white thing is
the result
of people who refuse to acknowledge the
problems in their community and look for
a scapegoat
if if there is an asian man who is
slashed across the face attacked by a
black person
race doesn't need to be the defining
like the law was broken
you can't slash people in the face what
happens then is you get these activists
these progressives
scapegoating the problem making it about
white nationalism instead of
general crime violence poverty etc so
the problem doesn't get solved
and then people who don't understand
what the march is all about
instead of going after the core issues
class issues for one
they then start saying we need to tell
everybody to be less white because you
see what happens to that poor asian man
i'm like that had nothing to do with it
now all of a sudden you get coca-cola
they don't know what that means be less
white they have no idea what that is
they read
robin d'angelo book that woman is an
avowed racist she says she's a racist
why are you teaching people to be like a
racist woman it makes no sense
it's it's funny because like when you
when you talk about this as someone
who's grown up in a different country
like that's australia and obviously
australia's pretty ethno-homogeneous in
the sense that you know i think the
population is 90
wide or something like that you have
this perception of the u.s when you come
here and then when you see what the
communities are like i agree with you in
the sense that
there's a lot of non-self accountability
that goes down
in particular communities that it and
as someone who has now lived in the us
for almost two years who's observed a
lot of it as a completely objective
third party observer i have no personal
interest
in like the the racial affairs of the
united states
but when i watch this stuff and when you
are
treated by in a certain way by
particular groups of people you come to
realize that it's not
the white population in my opinion maybe
i'm saying this because i'm a white
person that's probably what people would
say but
as a white person i don't think that
it's the white population that's even
the racist group in this country
i don't know if i don't know if you guys
would agree with that but as an outsider
someone who's come into it i think that
there's a lot of
i think you're wrong you think the white
population is the most racist
absolutely all the time all they're
called liberals yeah they're called
they're called democrats
no but generally like white like even i
know you guys are joking no no no no no
no no no white liberals are yeah for
sure but like
normal people you and me i don't i don't
care what you look like just be normal
to me
right right right listen listen i i
think i understand what you're trying to
say
that you're you're talking about like
negative racism where
someone would attack a person of another
race right no i'm talking about the fact
that like
america so i don't see white people
going around and going you know what we
should do we should put anyone who's not
white in internment camps
that's the see that's one aspect of
racism when you have a bunch of white
people
saying white is bad so there's a chart
that shows
in-group out-group preference among
different races and
uh they split up white by liberal and
conservative
liberals are the only group with an
out-group preference
white liberals are quite literally the
most racist
so the in-group preference among black
asian
you know latino is less i believe
than the out-group preference of white
liberals but i don't
consider their opinions when i talk
about anything because i think they're
so radical and
like i really do i think they're so
radical that i don't i don't even
register
the far left to me these these the
people that you're talking about
to me they're so far gone that they i
don't even register this
this is major companies these these are
the establishment pushing these talking
points we're talking about
governments universities high schools
major corporations pushing
these talking points these lectures by
robin d'angelo this this white woman
who's trying to make sure people don't
understand that she's also white
uh she's racist she says she's racist
yes it's when do we take our talking
points from racism coca-cola employs a
large
number of employees and this influence
this
kind of uh you know conjecture of how
bad it is to be white how bad it is to
be born of a certain
dna you know assembly
it's just absolutely ridiculous but this
is the institutions that
set policies these are young minds of
children that are being taught this
in in schools every single day this is
going to become the new norm
this kind of line of thinking if it's
not challenged and it's not challenged
it's coming back under the biden
presidency and it's going to be
institutionalized so much
to the point where this is the new
normal it already is institutionalized
i mean literally like the newest video
that i made i literally just posted this
yesterday
is about like i have a series white
people bad and it's basically just where
i find the most
ridiculous things on the internet of
people um
i'm trying not to swear to him i'm
trying to think of words people just
attacking white people over just
nonsense and there was one thing that i
found that
really disturbed me and it came from i
believe the original post was basically
white people can experience murder
and i and i went and looked into that
yeah it was mental i went and looked at
it
i looked into it a little bit and i
believe that it's more or less a troll
post came from like 4chan you know where
they want to like roll people up
because i couldn't find it on any lefty
forums but when i read it i was like
this sounds like saying a regressive
leftist would say
but that's that was not the disturbing
part the disturbing thing
was a video that i found that had been
um screened effectively at a
university so to speak in san francisco
called why don't we murder
more white people what um what
yes what yup no no it's i like i
encourage people i'm not going to float
my own channel but
i put a bunch of clips in this video um
no it's just i mean like i just it was
the name of the video
the video on my channel that you did
about this white people bad part three
okay that's the easy title so let's
listen
it's literally the noise viewer but this
thing was mental i oh my gosh
uh the area i grew up in was very was
very just mixed a bunch of different you
know with polish immigrants we had
latino we had asian we had black people
and we all got along with each other and
i think it was because we all live next
to each other you know what i mean
when when you say do you don't think
white people are the most racist
i would say if you have this view of
racism as like a guy walks into a store
and they say we don't serve your kind
round these parts
but we're talking about understanding
literal racism the white progressives in
this country
are substantially exponentially more
racist than any other group i've ever
encountered
i i've i've been all over the country
i've been all over the planet and it was
it was amazing when i first went to
occupy wall street so i had before i
could watch it i hadn't left
the country but i'd been all over the
country in various places i had been in
conservative areas that have been on a
military basis
i got to you know i hung out with people
who are religious and pro-life
and i really didn't think racism was all
that
prominent i thought like this is it like
we've done away with these old
stereotypes
there's still problems you know the
remnants of blockbusting and redlining
persisted into the 80s and still exist
in some forms today
but i'm like man we really are winning
and crushing these these racists
and then i went to occupy wall street
and the progressives
segregated everybody based on race into
different groups
based on their race and your voting
privileges
in the community was determined
partially based on your race
so they had some groups where it was
like the black caucus got a vote in how
money was spent simply because it was a
group of black people
but then you had like the sanitation
working group they got a vote on
spending money based on the fact that
they all cleaned
and were sanitary and so i was like i
don't understand why voting power is
derived based on the fact that you're a
group of people based on race
and they were like you just don't
understand because you know we got to
just you know break down all the racism
whatever
there was one black dude at occupy wall
street not super involved and he was
chilling
i saw him arguing with somebody one day
that's not a ducati park and i overheard
him talking
and then he was disparaging occupy wall
street it's interesting
so i went to him i was like i was like
hey bro you're hanging out here you
think this is crazy
and he went bro do you have any idea
what the press would say if they found
out y'all are segregating people based
on race into different colored groups
that's crazy
and i was like i agree with you these
people are nuts i had never experienced
that kind of racism in my life
i have i have met racist redneck
conservative types
and i have heard them say horrible
things but it's it's always like
so i had an uber driver once who was
like it was in virginia
and this guy was super racist he slowly
started
we were talking about politics and then
he mentioned something particularly
racist and then immediately walked it
back
because he knew it was not socially
acceptable so that guy was a racist
but he couldn't say it these
progressives flaunt it they they shout
to the high heavens we are racist they
scream
and then write books about it and
coca-cola hires them to teach their
employees how to be racist
welcome to america 2021 it's insane one
of the other interesting aspects of
occupy wall street being there from the
very beginning to the very end
was to see it kind of emerge into two
different classes we had the
we had the uptown area which which had
all the liberals and all the white
people in the libraries and then we had
the downtown area
and then the uptown and the downtown
area had an internal conflict and fight
within occupy wall street so seeing
these social dynamics kind of recreate
and
recreate itself in our main society was
amazing and incredible to see in real
life
as it kind of unfolded on this kind of
time scale but another thing i wanted to
bring up
babylon b made some really good points
today and they brought up seven points
about how to be less white
uh if you don't mind i'm gonna read some
of them i'm not gonna read all of them
but i think there's some important
takeaways here
number five it says throw away all of
your ranch dressing
ranch dressing mayo it's all gotta go no
i love mayo number seven it says hate
yourself
every walking moment until you have
sufficiently atoned to your whiteness
oops spoiler alert you'll never
sufficiently atone for your whiteness
better go back to step three step three
no
step three is to you know
terminate yourself terminate functions
yeah terminate your internal functions
from
uh working as a human being and then and
then there you go
racism ended forever so babylon be uh
pretty interesting it is rip off
like that's what's what's weird is
they're making a joke but did you guys
see that cut video that came out like
three months ago that talked about like
all the
reasons why people are the worst in the
world like what are white people
superior
did you guys see that no okay i'm
surprised you didn't cause this this
viewer basically
see it yeah i'm like i'm sure i'm sure
you guys did like
basically it was it was a group of um
they collected a hundred black
folks with an ex love that for them and
got them in a room and said what are
white people superior at and it starts
off like real light-hearted like haha
mayonnaise like
okay you know white people love they
dogs at one bit and then it goes into oh
they're better at oppression they're
better at white supremacy they're better
at murder they're better
it's so not true because i gotta be
honest asians are in are just so much
better at a lot of these things
japanese mongolia would like to speak to
you japan
japan wants to have a conversation guys
japan has a lot to say about this
i found out that i was i always i always
thought i was a quarter korean
and then i found out i'm actually five
percent japanese through dna tests
and then i was like you know why that
happened but yeah
no but i mean this is the thing is you
make jokes about it but then you go and
watch this content that mind you is
still up on youtube doesn't break any
freaking guidelines and things that has
people literally saying that white
people are the best at oppression
okay well thank you well what uh let's
let's say good things
uh what what what what uh are white
people good at
um tan no figure skating is that true
no no country dancing square yes yes
square dancing yep
uh capitalism yes it even feels dirty to
say
i don't know no one's white
it's such a weird phrase they're they're
wailing actually no it's not even true
japanese
way better what the heck calling fishing
dna is better than others let me tell
you about skateboarding stereotypes
i'll tell you about skateboarding types
right these are stereotypes that i'm not
saying are true
but were brought up to me when i was
young in skateboarding
asian skateboarders tend to be good at
technical skateboarding which means
they can do extremely complicated
maneuvers so it's like combining the
most tricks into one trick
uh black skateboarders tend to and again
this is a stereotype that the skate you
know people in skateboarding have said
tend to be able to ollie better than
anybody and and do some of like the best
flat ground skating
and then white people are really good at
jumping off buildings
no joke no joke these are the
stereotypes so like
this is again i'm not saying i agree
with them or even support these ideas
but these are stereotypes that emerge
so when people joke i'll tell you this
too you want to hear racism
but that no one cares about go to a
skate park and you'll hear the n word
more more times than you've ever heard
in your life
and nobody cares it's all just like
urban culture i get you get people of
all different races saying it over and
over again
so these are stereotypes that get
brought up and so what typically what's
what people will say is like when they
talk about you know what are white
people good at it's like man they can
jump off buildings and jump down
railings
basically and this does align kind of
with conquest and oppression in my
opinion
war you know world war europe a lot of
conflict
and i was reading about this and they
and i was reading that was because
population density in europe with
nowhere to go
whereas in north america asia and africa
you actually can flee
in the event of conflict in crisis in
europe they couldn't so those who
survived were those willing to fight
more
you know that makes sense i don't know
that's true though you know but it does
fall in like kind of what they were
saying about oppression or whatever
well i mean like i guess that some of
the biggest empires were what roman
greek no no the uh honey they said uk
yeah well i don't know the spanish the
french
but who are the biggest because then if
we really want to i mean like english
the english empire was what that took
over like 40
genghis khan as well he was he was
pretty dope man
not so much but he i watched marco polo
recently that that show
honestly he was pretty good i learned
some stuff apparently it's changus not
genghis so i've been saying it wrong my
whole life wait it's chengiskan
apparently it's a c c sound rather than
a g sound so i've been
saying that wrong i heard he enforced
civil rights
yeah he was a weird one because he even
though he took over so much land it was
almost like what the romans did where
the romans went in and were like okay
this is
ours now you can still do your own thing
but we're still going to tax you and
whatever but you can stay here and do
whatever but
what he i figured out what people are
good at what communism oh yeah
wait no no they're not good at it they
failed every time everyone did
everything but
100 percent of the time but karl marx
invented it or like
he didn't invent it he like kind of
wrote about it with his friends now
there was a racist
oh my goodness if you look at his
letters oh my
yeah don't i don't isn't it weird that
all these people that like
white liberals uphold to this standard
are honestly some of the worst humans
when it comes to the treatment of other
racial groups yeah
uh tong i don't know
what like well you know you know it was
really it was really so i you know
listening to the beatles
you have uh the song revolution and he
has that line
when i was a little kid i did not
understand what this meant but if you go
carrying pictures of chairman
mao you ain't gonna make it make it with
anyone anyhow apparently you will
i was a little kid i didn't understand
what that meant i was just like huh
chairman yeah
like you know and i was like a little
kid singing beatles and like you know
running around playing guitar whatever
and then i got older and i was like oh i
get it he was saying yo
don't support authoritarian communists
bro like that's pretty legit
yeah and uh i don't know maybe his
message didn't work out all that well
yeah well obviously it didn't yeah
because these people are all about it
yep yeah yeah they wanna they wanna turn
america into what like a socialist
utopia
i'm excited i can't wait to be like
standing in my bread line
you know getting like besieged oh my god
i can't wait so excited
i'm stoked yeah it's gonna be great yeah
my family doesn't have good reviews
no communism from what they went through
how many stars
how many stars uh zero
there's no stars in communism there's
only other redistribution
stars for everyone of course everyone
gets a star
everybody gets one one only one yes all
right so well let's
let's use this as a point to uh jump to
the next story oh yeah so this is
something
i was talking about earlier it's from
the daily mail democratic
representatives right to cable companies
including at t
and comcast and streamers amazon and
hulu demanding they drop
fox news oan and newsmax over
misinformation
i didn't want to jump into this like
we're coming off the other segment but
we
did that whole spiel with the coca-cola
thing but uh
this is interesting to me because
basically we can see like disney
claiming muppets are racist and all that
stuff so so let me get this straight
disney is allowed to literally run a
show
of racist muppets but tucker carlson
should be pulled off the air
that's that's basically what they're
saying when democrats write to these
cable companies to remove
conservative news channels also i mean
the ramifications of this this is the
government
agents of the government trying to force
private companies into shutting down
their political rivals
to be fair tucker carlson kind of looks
like one of the muppets i forgot which
one
uh but there's like a news reporter one
but he does
it's a compliment also another thing
they're going after fox news for
spreading misinformation and quote
conspiracy theories i mean
these are from democratic congress
members calling for ceos of tv companies
and internet providers to take down
another news channel that doesn't
subscribe to the same notions
i don't like fox i i made a shirt
against fox even myself
even cnn with the toilet and everything
i don't like any of these kind of
partisan networks but the bigger kind of
understanding here is if these people
are going to take them down for
misinformation and conspiracy theories
they have to take themselves down at the
same time i thought of a funny joke
did you so we were just talking about
the previous segment like what are white
people good at
and then you mentioned some people said
oppression yeah but
you see they only steal that from china
right so i was i'm looking we're looking
at the story and i'm like i'm thinking
about
these like these these democrats trying
to get news banned and i'm like man
maybe they really are good at oppressing
wait a minute
what they're doing is a rip-off of what
china already did
and then i thought it's another funny
joke because then the other stereotype
about white people that you get from the
progressives is that they steal culture
so maybe right now the democrats are
really good at stealing the
authoritarianism from these
despotic nations hey and now there you
go it's an idea
that is an idea i mean look i think
china was very good
at banning basically all media that
didn't agree with the government
so i mean they're like right ahead of us
yeah they are yeah i'm sorry just
these white progressives are just not
good at oppression no they're trying
though
is this cultural appropriation then are
they appropriating yes
so yeah i mean culturally oh oh they
should stop they shouldn't
yeah i'm sorry it is racist for them to
try and shut down
opinions of those they don't like
exactly because they're just ripping off
china there you go
take note liberals take note what is
this what does this look ian
stroking your beauty i'm taking it
[Laughter]
look this is uh uh i wonder to what
degree this is a violation of the first
amendment
for for trying to shut down all the news
yeah well what these what these
democrats are doing they're acting
they act their their their agents of
government and they're going and trying
to get
political views taken off they're not
going to these channels
they're literally going to to the
providers and saying you know why are
you still hosting them this
misinformation these lies
i mean this is the kind of stuff that
makes me pessimistic it makes me feel
like we're headed towards
absurdity it's like you've got
authoritarianism they don't they're
doing too much
these these politicians it's if you're
driving down the road on a freeway you
don't need to be turning left and right
and it's like we got people in jobs that
don't need to be there anymore or
something
they don't need to change it you know
what you like you've talked about this
before ian that like maybe we don't need
these politicians anymore
you mentioned like less politicians and
like different branches and stuff like
that
i'm wondering if you know what why do
they make new laws you know what i mean
they're constantly making new laws why
don't they get rid of old ones well
that's the thing is like
so with this whole lockdown stuff and
this is totally an aside but it
goes to what you said i always think
like governments are really good at
stomping on your freedoms how often do
they give them back
so it's like when when they legislate
it's like you said like for every and i
think that was trump's thing
you know for every how many laws were
passed you know however many were
repealed and i think that or you know
all this red tape was cut and i think
that you're right like they're always
passing new laws but it's like
for what what are you doing actually day
to day that is necessary that needs to
be done it's more regulation
most of the time taking your guns away
yes they're getting there they're trying
so yeah they did it in australia oh they
did and then after they took away the
firearms in australia the australian
government
locked down and clamped down on its
citizenry uh
more than almost any government out
there especially when it came to the
covid restrictions and it was kind of
it still is absurd to see what they're
able to get away with over there oh it's
terrible
like i don't know so aussies and i i
think have just a fundamental
disagreement some of these and i have a
fundamental disagreement when it comes
to this this is part of why i left
because my frustration was like i'm
watching america which mind you i know
that a lot of americans think that
america is just rightly screwed right
now
to some extent maybe but you still have
a constitution and a bill of rights and
a bunch of stuff that protects you
australians not so much we don't have
freedom of speech that's an implied
thing in our constitution
we don't have a bill of rights we have
five rights in our constitution and
there are things like freedom or
religion and you know you can move
between states and things like that
so watching what was going down with all
the lockdown stuff having no guns yada
yada yada
it was honestly really you know i'm here
in the us and i'm thinking
i'm so lucky to live in a country where
i can actually just basically be like
you know what nah and do what i want
i think that that's great even living in
texas you can just buy a million guns in
there was people who organized protests
on facebook and literally had police
officers break down their front door
when they were having dinners with their
family with children there
and arrested and took them away from
their children for
organizing a protest oh yeah yeah that
was one there was a pregnant girl
this one i believe you're talking about
yeah there's a number of them yeah yeah
um it's funny because one of my very
good friends back home his name is avi
and he's a journalist for
rebel news um he was he's been arrested
several times now
even though he has press credentials
from the government to be you know at
these protests and things and he has
been arrested he's been chucked in the
back of the divi van where the the
police van thingy
um and they they really target the
journalists now they arrested one i
think it was two or three days ago they
arrest another young journalist and her
photographer from the herald sun which
is another
melbourne newspaper and the thing that
really distresses me watching this like
again from a country where i can
basically do a lot of things that i
can't do back home
is they just snap their fingers and go
okay we're having another lock down our
five day lock down everyone like stay in
your home can't go outside can't do this
can't do that and australians just go
okay yes daddy government yes yes yes
i'll do the thing
okay yup and i it makes me want to throw
up because i think
where is your sense of freedom where's
your sense of self-preservation it's not
i mean they think that the government
will answer all of their hopes and
dreams and questions when in reality
the government is actually just stomping
on you the first the first 15 days
we all basically agreed exactly after
three weeks 15 days two weeks so this
week
yeah and we were all like yeah that
makes sense but then when they extended
it we still agreed we were like all
right
let's let's let's slow this thing down
we're all in this together right
and then after i think the first year
like where we're at now everyone's kind
of like dude come on man
yeah look at look you look at
we're looking at global food shortages
we're looking at massive poverty
and it it feels like they're just
destroying everything on purpose
because they don't care they don't care
that lives are being ruined
they don't how many politicians took a
pay
like had a decrease in pay during this
time how many politicians didn't get
paid i think they all got paid
you know the premiere of in victoria so
where i'm from the premiere of my home
state gave himself a pay raise
during the pandemic after he locked down
victorians for the longest period i'm
pretty sure in the entire world
and then this i want to call him the c
word but i'm not going to say it but
then he goes
he goes and gives him and i had nearly
slipped out i was like sydney
he goes and gives himself a pay raise
how many of these people and even in the
u.s
how many of them have taken a pay cut
how many of them have not yet gotten
paid andrew cuomo got a raise
he's he's working very hard oh yeah for
these people he deserves more
daily press conferences lying to you
giving you his little smile he's a
sociopath they're not lies
they're comforting distortions he's
trying to just
avert panic and make everyone feel good
oh and it does they feel really
you know what the thing is if you value
security more than freedom i don't know
what to tell you
and it's not misinformation it's
comfortable news
comfortable comfort this guy is that you
guys should go look him up you'll have a
field day
especially tim yeah we uh
i i'm glad i don't live in australia
because where is it like victoria is
that the the what are they
is it called a state or is it a province
or what is it state yeah we have states
states and territories yeah and that's
where they basically
put everybody in like home jail home
home arrest or whatever yeah basically
yeah i mean like
again aussies look i love australians
but sometimes you know they get on me
and they're like you're so mean where's
some unibodies truly and i'm like i
don't know because you got no freedom
like
i don't know wait you're you're half
american though right yeah
so that's that's the thing you're a day
walker you you understand
that it seems like you've got the best
uh you inherited the best of both sides
like the ability to fight giant
tarantulas
and like kangaroos while understanding
the importance of freedom
yeah exactly that's the craziest thing
to me is that you could have australia
which is the stereotypic stereotypical
stereotypical death trap country
of like giant spiders and birds i watch
this video where there's a super
jacked kangaroo banging on some guy's
window you saw that one yeah yeah yeah
and he's like what's
and i this australian guy i knew said
like they could gut you they could like
their huge claws oh yeah
slash you i'm like how do you grow up in
a place where i watched one video where
these people are like drinking on an
outdoor patio and a kangaroo just like
stomps through
yeah and but you know what maybe that's
actually what it is they're scared of
everything
and so when the government comes in
they're like please help us from the
giant mean monsters
no and so they hide they hide you know
look i grew up uh in the country so
we're always around ruse and stuff they
are very aggressive people need to
understand don't chase them
do not corner them you're going to get
your little face ripped off they are
they've got these little creases right
you see them like flex
oh yeah they are they're dressed i think
it's bigger than this tim i think it's
the queen
she has to be responsible for her you're
right luke yeah i keep thinking about it
canada the united kingdom australia
toughest strictest lockdowns all of them
colonies are the queen yeah it's all the
commonwealth starting isn't it yep
no i mean that's actually i wonder
because i know that i don't actually
don't
that was not a nonsensical sentence you
also you also have to look at new
zealand too because they have been like
i love it i love it when people are like
new zealand's dealing with this so well
new zealand's an island in the middle of
the pacific with nothing around it
except other oceans and a very small
population is a tiny population isn't it
2 000 miles from australia
i i don't know in terms of proximity
it's it's like a three-hour plane ride
to get to new zealand that sounds like
about 2 000. well if you look in the
united kingdom i mean
even their lockdowns are absolutely
absurd and
very oddly yeah it doesn't make many
sense
on many different levels because if you
look at the numbers you compare it to
sweden um the numbers are going down the
same way they're even going down even
more according to some estimates in
sweden
where the lockdowns were restricted by
and large
not fully but by and large compared to
the united kingdom that fully lock down
and of course has their police officers
sending out notices that they will no
longer be responding to burglaries
but they spent taxpayer money on
billboard buses telling you that being
offensive
is a criminal offense oh you know the uk
is
just oh god it's beautiful it's again
it's one of these beautiful prisons
it's australia is a beautiful prison
aussies don't yell at me for saying that
love you
this is a bit of a prison bloody you
know gulag i think it's about
the uk yeah they're beautiful but
they're prisons because like
you know these are countries that arrest
people not australia so much they do it
a little bit but not that much but they
arrest people for things they post
online and it's like
it's ridiculous oh my god 2583.3 miles
new zealand to australia i just think
that's relevant because people think
australia and new zealand are very close
to each other
no they're it's a yeah it's super fast
yeah definitely
and i think new zealand has like four
million people five million i think five
million yeah when i went to new zealand
they asked me why i was there and i was
going there to interview this guy gareth
morgan
and they all knew who he was so when i
was at like the the immigration
checkpoint
they were like what you're here for mike
i'm here with you know vice magazine
we're going to interview this guy
and they're like who is it and i was
like his name's gareth morgan oh i know
him
and i was like you're doing the like
there's not that many people in this
country man
it's like everybody knows if someone
here is famous everybody knows who it is
i was expecting you to do a an accent it
sounded like you were going there i was
i was i was gearing up i was like oh tim
i almost did i almost went for it well
you know tough one it's it's
you know i used to do a really good new
zealand accent but i've got to hear it
first and it's been too long so like i
wouldn't get it i'm unable to just
get my toes in a little bit you have a
like a day walker accent
my accent is just an absolute mess and
honestly it depends who i'm around to
because if i'm a
if i'm around a bunch of yanks i feel
like my accent gets much more american
when i'm around other yeah yeah you guys
are yanks all of you like no matter
where you're from you're all yanks
but when i talk to like you know if i
call home and i'm talking to like my dad
who is
very australian he's from perth so his
accent is just like off the planet
um but if i like call home or something
people are like oh you're just
you're using your own terminology again
i'm like yeah my accent sucks it's
don't ask i don't know did you live in
the u.s for a long forever
before no no i'm just you know it's
funny when people are like
so um are you putting this on i'm like
yeah i'm trying to do both accents badly
yeah your mom was american my mom's
american okay but moved over there
yep fell in love fell in love with my
dad citizenship
yep um so i mean i got questions about
the british monarchy
growing up were you like were you
were you aware that you lived under the
rule of a queen
she said she was the head of state yeah
she's our head but it's very like
subversive
you don't know you're kind of led to
believe that you live in a free state
yeah yeah yeah
so when i became aware of the fact that
because obviously like when you're at
school you learn about aussie history
you don't learn about british history
you learn about aussie history you learn
about federation
you know like when um the first fleet
landed in australia and colonized yada
yada we learn about all of that
um i didn't know probably until i was
actually
maybe in my late teens that we weren't a
republic
because i remember we studied stuff at
school and i was like oh well you know i
would probably vote to have us be a
republican i had friends who were like
no
i want to be you know we need them on
our case deal and that's a whole it's
actually a whole argument is a lot of
conservatives in australia
are like we need to still be part of you
know or at least have the monarchy as
like our head of state so to speak even
though it's
the queen we she gives royal ascent on
all of our legislation that gets passed
so i mean it's it's more of a ceremonial
thing but it's still active i guess
like she controls the military and so
she is she the one ordering these
lockdowns
no but she's not saying no to them she's
she's she's dissenting to them
what if there's like a secret conspiracy
where the queen
actually is giving instructions to her
subjects and she's actually controlling
new zealand and australia well i think
it's funny to call it a conspiracy when
she's literally the queen the monarch
the head of state
for the soul god given leader of the
country
by divine providence she's queen of the
britons
you want to talk about corrupt
institutions that have ties to
children that do bet i can't even say it
the royal family my goodness gracious
there's
prince deep down the rabbit holes that
you could go down just them i heard
rabbit hole
they're bad yeah speaking of rabbit hole
yeah
so uh what an excellent segue luke that
was perfect timing
my friends we have to talk about this uh
i'm ashamed of each and every one of you
oh
luke ian sydney lydia yeah critical
thinking
what were you thinking the new york
times says critically critical thinking
and uh hold on i want to read this for
you there's a quote from the new york
times critical thinking as we're taught
to do it
isn't helping in the fight against
misinformation wait wait
check out this first line all right for
an academic
michael caulfield has an odd request
stop overthinking what you see
online sit down shut up
believe what you're told and move on
good sir yes sir
the new york times this is what they say
mr coffield the digital literacy expert
washington state
knows all too well in vancouver mind you
knows all too well at this very moment
more people are fighting for the
opportunity to lie to you than perhaps
any other point in human history
misinformation blah blah blah yeah we
get it
we're taught that in order to protect
ourselves from bad information we need
to deeply engage with the stuff that
washes up in front of us
mr coffield told me recently he
suggested that the dominant mode of
media literacy
if kids get taught any at all and that's
a good point is that quote
you'll get imperfect information and
then use reasoning to fix that somehow
but in reality
that strategy can completely backfire in
other words resist the lure of rabbit
holes in part
by reimagining media literacy for the
internet hellscape we occupy
let me tell you what's really being said
here because i can translate for all of
you
they don't want you investigating the
news they don't want you listening to
conversations like this
you want to know how easy it is i'll
give you i'll tell you guys all this
how do you know who's actually lying
who's telling the truth the person who's
telling you the truth tells you
to listen to the ideas of other people
and come to your own conclusion to be a
free sovereign individual why
i don't want power over you i don't want
to own your life or rule your life or
make you do anything for me i want you
to find what's best for you that
empowers other people
the people who would tell you don't
think critically don't
don't investigate these things don't
watch these other channels
they do want things from you they want
to manipulate they want to control you
they want you for a purpose
i don't care what you do i don't care if
you want to go home yourself like a
banana and juggle bananas i don't care
if you'll dress up like a clown and go
to a clown party that's your thing you
do your thing
anybody telling you not to do what you
want to do to be free songs you're not
hurting others
and who would lie to you and tell you
not to listen to others or would censor
opinions
or my stars and garters new york times
saying don't think critically
well they say people are manipulating
but the way they phrase that critical
thinking as we're taught
so maybe what they're implying is we're
not being taught proper critical
thinking skills and i can kind of
identify
what maybe he's saying is that there's a
propensity when you're reading something
to
just disbelieve it like you don't want
to believe everything you see obviously
but you don't want to necessarily
disbelieve it either so
to rebuff ideas and to become so you
know contrastual
just as a reflex is also a problem and
maybe that's what a lot of people are
doing
it's a it's a fair point to say don't go
down the rabbit hole
because then people become flat earthers
and other weird stuff
but then saying critical thinking as
we're taught no no no look i mean i get
the point for sure i'll give them
the benefit of the doubt what they're
really saying is actually think
critically
they're not saying that the opening line
was don't overthink things
so what i open the newspaper and it says
x just happened
the the an american destroyer was
attacked in the gulf of tonkin
don't overthink it it just happened
except it is reality
and then you know the vietnam war starts
and we find out later and it didn't
really happen
and you know and maybe we should have
overthought that i feel like when you're
at university there's like a big thing
where you are taught
not well to think critically i don't
know if that was you know
anyone else's experience but that was
definitely mine and i feel like maybe
that
i don't think that's what the new york
times is saying just by the way like i
definitely think this is them being like
don't look too deeply into things
because
then you might start questioning
narratives that you're not supposed to
question
but certainly sorry how are you taught
critically like what was yours i just
don't feel like we were i feel like it
was one of those things where like
when i was at school and i so my first
degree was i i studied criminology and
then my second my master was in
journalism
because you know here i am sort of doing
that um but i feel like there wasn't a
huge
emphasis on actually digging deeper into
things it was sort of like accept this
on the surface
and maybe look a little bit into it here
are the sources the approved sources
that we're okay with you looking at
don't go beyond these or if you do look
at these these and these and these
because these are you know supplementary
readings but it wasn't like go and do
your own research and then write me
something new and impressive
that wasn't the emphasis and i feel like
that's what critical thinking is taking
a prompt or an idea or whatever reading
something about it going okay
and then looking deeper and then going
down this hall and going over here and
and basically building
an idea of something from multiple
angles and sources and coming to your
own conclusions we're not taught to do
that i wasn't taught to do that at
school
at university and i feel like a lot of
young people coming out of that system
probably don't have the skills that they
should when it comes to thinking more in
depth about things i'm not saying that
everyone has to be conservative
or has to solely go to conservative
sources and that's all they can read and
that's the only place that's going to
give them true and accurate information
no
look at everything across the board and
then derive your conclusions yeah
times have changed in the last 20 years
especially with the internet because now
looking at everything is impossible
there's so much information relative to
1996
when i was you know in school you can
more easily find the sources
so if someone makes a claim and you
can't verify the source you can question
it
and and hold it in doubt we used to
trust it more when the new york times
would come out and say anonymous source
told us this people would be like
i guess it's true because what else we
gonna do about it now we can actually be
like hold on let me look into that
but here's the dangerous thing about
what what the new york times is doing
they hold themselves to a special
standard that's basically it in in the
article they say you know here's some
four principles of what you should do
when you encounter you know potential
disinformation or whatever they say
one stop two investigate the source
three find better coverage
four trace claims quotes and media to
the original context otherwise known as
sift
here's a quote is robert f kennedy jr
the best
unbiased source on information about a
vaccine i'd argue no
and that's good enough to know we should
probably just move on he said
and i'd like to edit in a little
sentence while completely ignoring bill
gates is not a scientist nor a doctor
you see the point when bill gates comes
out they say
everything oh it's great bill gates has
a plan and here's what he's saying
here's his advice
in the new york times says well robert f
kennedy jr was an anti-vaxxer so don't
trust him
it's they apply this standard of we must
not overthink things and must analyze
only when it's the narrative they want
so a good example is how like wikipedia
works for example i can come out and say
something like i am in favor of
a universal health care system that also
has
private health insurance much like most
of the developed world
i am not in favor of abolishing private
uh insurance and i was a big fan of
bernie sanders
in 2016 and they'll say tim poole is not
a good source
on what he actually believes even when
he says it but then i can come out and
say something like i am
pro 2a and they'll write tim pool says
he is full pro 2a
if it is a right-wing position they'll
say well he said it so it's true
if it's a left-wing position they'll say
nope nope he's not a good source of this
information so tim pool can't be
left-wing
they use whatever narrative they want
they use the rules
only when it best suits them don't think
critically they say
unless of course it's negative you know
something negative against our opponents
in which case you must think critically
and sift and go through the sources
that's the name of the game i suppose
that's something media sucks though this
is why the media is i just
i'm going to start but i mean this is
where the mainstream is
this is just why the mainstream media
really gets under my skin because you're
right like
and i think a lot of conservatives
obviously like being that that's the
space that i occupy a lot of the time is
that conservative libertarian-esque
ground but
a lot of people on the right too i don't
think are willing to admit that the
right wing
is just as bad when it comes to spinning
things or hint cherry-picking
information
and creating particular narratives
around things where they're not quite
telling the truth
for example i mean like even that coke
thing and i'm not defending what coke
did at all i think it
that's gross but i mean they put out a
statement that basically said hey you
know um
this is not actually the sole focus of
our curriculum it was just part i know
and you're making a face at me but i'm
just saying like there's
there's that caveat to the story that i
think they're buttholes for what they
did and i think it's disgusting and i
you know like i said i put that in the
video i made i you know i'm trying not
to swear tim it's so hard for me to try
to find it
for the after show but it's you know i
so so my my point here is that you're
allowed to be like coke or a bunch of
buttholes and i think that they suck
you know what they did was shitty and
sorry i was trying i was trying to avoid
it i was trying
you can't help it it was just trying to
get out you did it
what they did was yucky and we don't
like it and that you know whatever
but then you caveat you go but this is
also what they said because then it's a
more
you've you know you you're not being
dishonest there's no twist on there i
don't who's being
who's being dishonest i'm not saying
anyone was being dishonest but i'm
saying that in this context
i'll tell you i'll tell you more
information is better in my opinion
i took issue with the wind wind turbine
story in texas
because all the conservatives like not
all of them but all of these
conservatives are coming out and saying
the wind turbines froze and it shut down
the grid and it caused all the damage
and in reality also gas lines were
freezing and there was a bunch of other
issues
but it does seem because we did have on
one fellow was an uh
energy expert who basically said if it
wasn't
for the wind turbines going down the
demand for gas wouldn't have skyrocketed
causing this you know domino effect
essentially
but to come out and say that it was the
sole reason for the crisis was
not completely true right so you have
aoc coming out and saying no it's the
problem of the gas lines we need a green
new deal
many on the right saying it's the wind
turbines and i'm like the reality is
they didn't winterize the wind turbines
right there there are wind turbines in
antarctica
and they work because it doesn't snow so
in texas they needed to better winterize
them and prepare for this and it seems
like they weren't prepared for a winter
storm
even though it happened in 2011 right so
it's not entirely
yes there it's fair to say that when the
wind turbines froze up it caused a
cascade effect
texas could have prepared now i hear
them saying that joe biden denied
some emergency relief so it's always
much more complicated than anything
but i will tell you this for the most
part conservatives know what the left is
thinking
and when they write about it they don't
need to snub details
they might give you their biased version
of it sure but the left outright just
manipulates
oh i'm not saying that conservatives
like lie in the same way that the left
does
definitely not but they definitely they
still spin things i still see things and
i go
i know for a fact that what is written
in this article is part of the story
and there's a whole other element to
this that if they just added a single
sentence acknowledging that other part
of it
it would be a more holistic better
well-rounded story that people could
read and go okay i
now at least know basically more or less
the full details of it i'm not saying
that
i mean the left just make crap up that's
the thing that headbutting microphones
here that's the thing that annoys me so
much is they just make things up but i
don't know i hate the media in general
like across the board just because of
this the dishonesty and the twisting of
information
i got a a correction and i'm actually
really happy about this
so pointer i did i did a segment on this
on my tim cast news channel
so i i tweeted something very snarky i
said
time magazine just came out and said
that a cabal rigged the election
i'm sorry they said they didn't rig the
election they fortified it
by changing the rules and the laws and
manipulating the flow of information
it was just snarky but i made no
declaration in this
time magazine said this and then i said
they
i'm sorry they didn't say it was rigged
because i was trying to be silly so
pointer writes an article
and they said a controver you know
controversial youtuber tim poole
published a post which claimed or which
said the election was rigged you see how
they use weasel words to get through
that because
but the tweet did not say that in fact
the tweet said it isn't rigged it's
fortified
so they use that as a manipulation
here's the best part so this one outlet
i'm not gonna name because they did me
the solid they apologized corrected
immediately and
fixed the context in full which did
something amazing
in the full context from this pointer
article it says tim poole's post was
wrong
it claimed the election was rigged i
never said that i never said the
election was rigged
i never said trump really won i've long
said it's over biden one and i got so
many trump supporters who are mad at me
for it for a long time
smack talking me saying he's not he's
you know he's he's going against trump
whatever
so they put this claim out there they
then got mad because what happened was
bird watch
twitter's independent user fact checking
system
determined that my tweet was incr in
fact correct
not misleading it said and all the
responses where people say tim poole is
just referencing a time magazine article
he's citing a
time magazine article so another outlet
sees the pointer article and rewrites it
because this is what news outlets do
it's called journalism
churn like they just see a story they
read it in this
the the context evolved once more
poynter wrote in a post from
controversial youtuber
that stated the election was rigged they
didn't say i said it
is it the post stated it so it's it's
clever weasel words
well this next outlet said tim poole who
wrote the election was rigged
i reached out to the writer and the the
manager for the company
and i said you know i humbly request a
retraction this is not correct
i said that it wasn't rigged that it was
fortified
i was just referencing a time magazine
article so in this new article this is
really amazing
they included my tweet and they removed
the part where it said
who wrote tim poole who wrote the
election was rigged and said
in a tweet from tim poole who cited a
time magazine article claiming that a
cabal of wealthy elites
were fortifying the election by changing
rules and controlling the flow of
information
twitter flagged it as misleading and
with that simple correction a legitimate
correction so
my my thanks to the writer on that that
was very uh honorable and this this
guy's particularly lefty uh
it changed the entire context of the
article before the article was saying
tim poole lied and twitter said it was
real news
by fixing the context of my tweet it
says tim poole was correct
the users correctly identified this and
pointer is angry about it
so the article has now become the
premier fact checking organization for
facebook pointer
is outraged that i made a factual tweet
that was it was just a snarky
statement that users flagged it as not
misleading
and made them mad because they lost
control of the narrative to a bunch of
random twitter users
so with that correction i'm actually
really really happy and uh
i'm not entirely hopeful that will
always be the case but that's good news
sounds like uh the dude from the second
article who's the company the second
i didn't name them um actually went and
read the time magazine article after you
requested the retraction
and then was like whoa this is just um
it just seems like it i don't know if
that's actually what happened
the great the crazy thing about how the
media works whoa
whoa then you got this time article by
the way
have you read that article yeah yeah i
did so psycho
there's a trick that i do on twitter
where i make statements that are vague
and i and i got to admit i learned this
like from michael malus totally legit
like
i love his tweets when he would respond
to trump saying we don't deserve him
and you're like you don't know if it's
saying it's a good or bad i love it it's
brilliant
and so i started making tweets where i
would just try to avoid a hard direct
partisan opinion the opinion would be a
neutral positive or negative opinion
and then you can see in the responses
from people what they think of you
so that tweet for instance where i said
time magazine said the election was
rigged i'm sorry they didn't say it was
rigged
was i insulting time magazine or was i
was i angry with time for
for lying or was i angry with the cabal
of wealthy elites truth be told both to
be honest
but i know to be precise with with my
language
so what's interesting is this guy from
poynter the pointer institute they
decide who gets to be a fact checker for
facebook
he read my tweet and said oh that
controversial tim poole
claiming the election's rigged the other
guy just wrote what the guy said
but when he actually read the tweet he
took it at face value
tim poole is referencing time magazine
that's it my face my question is if
someone is to change the rules of an
election
is that not rigging the election well i
i
i'm not i didn't say that yeah i would
not tim's not making a statement he's
just being neutral off the record he's
just trying to you know we're on the
record right now
the the point is my issue is i'm not
going to come out and say
the election is rigged it's it's not
it's fortified
time magazine said all right right time
magazine but then i said
they said it wasn't rigged because i was
just being snarky time magazine
literally said it wasn't rigging the
election it was fortifying it
the point i made in my video was how
would you define rigging something
if let's say you know let's say ian and
luke were going to race
and then i tied luke's shoelaces
together right see i was going to say
we'll just hobble one of you but you
went
down much nicer oh my goodness like
break a leg okay
i think i think hobbling is a reference
to tying a rope to a donkey's legs yeah
i think so
no i thought hobbling is where you get
like i watched a movie where this woman
just went
and just like smashed this guy's um
ankles together yeah
that sounds horrible all right with a
mallet look what film was that oh my god
what are you doing on the island let me
put it this way there's a reason why
we're all related to convicts
the rule changes uh benefited everybody
it was make it easier to vote but we
know
that democrats are more likely to vote
by mail so
while the rule change would have
benefited both sides democrats are more
likely to vote
so if luke and i were about to race and
i was like ah let's race on one of those
horizontal elevator things that at the
airports
where the ground is moving forward on it
and we run am i rigging the race
it would be more
if you said this uh let's say there's a
dude who's allergic to
peanuts and you are like we're gonna
race but
i think it's fair that we give everyone
a big jar of peanut butter for energy
well one guy you know peanut peanut
butter is normally good
your opponent can't eat it so you are
saying no
no we're giving peanut butter to
everyone it's not changing the rules
they favor us
they did it covertly whatever they did
they did covertly which is
well if we knew not a time no no that's
going to be that's the fault of the
media
they said they like in georgia in
pennsylvania where these rule changes
happened it was publicly known
but you rely on a national media to come
out and tell you what was happening
so the issue was that the the the
question of rigging is not about
it's it's not necessarily about whether
or not fraud occurred because that i
don't think i
don't think that's an issue here the
bigger issue is were the changes
constitutional
and uh and that's basically it the other
big news in that regard is that
the supreme court today said now
clarence thomas yeah yeah clarence
thomas was awesome
what'd he say so well so uh i'll let him
take this one
the pennsylvania pennsylvania's been
swinging because we because i've covered
this so much
and we had sean put on the show several
times pennsylvania sued arguing that the
mail-in voting law was unconstitutional
because
their constitution in pa state says
absentee ballots must be for this reason
and then they created universal mail-in
voting which basically negated absentee
voting
the lower court said you are correct and
will likely win on the merits
and then it got i think it got appealed
to the state supreme court
the state supreme court said you're too
late the merits don't matter this bill
was passed in fall of 2019
therefore it's done so they file they
filed an appeal at the supreme court
the supreme court today said it's a moot
point trump's not going to be president
so we refuse to hear this
clarence thomas got angry and he said he
basically said
if we wouldn't hear the case before the
election
and now we won't hear the case after the
election we have not
solved the problem of breaking the rules
in the election and it is not a moot
point and he was he was pissed
he dissented amazing he was the only one
yeah
anyone on the show justice clarence
yes that would be incredible i would
love to have him he's amazing but
yeah he's this guy yeah he's a busy guy
um
be that that'd be awesome he's a rad
dude uh anyway the point is isn't he the
one that
um biden actually like gunned for a
couple years ago was that him like in
the 90s yeah yeah back when there were
his uh
hearings when he was uh going to be when
he was appointed he had to go through
the senate hearings and uh yeah biden
really went brutally yeah awfully yeah
so i mean like wouldn't surprise me if
that guy's like well
i'm biden i'm not the biggest fan this
is the question of rigging
right rigging is typically understood to
mean that you are
setting up a system to favor one
participant or one competitor or
something like that
and it doesn't necessarily mean cheating
although it's
kind of considered to be a cheater kind
of move you know what i mean i thought
rigging was where you're setting
something up to ensure that one
person wins or comes out victorious or
whatever to the detriment of other
people i don't even think that
i think if you rig a system you're just
changing the way the system works
yeah that's actually just setting up
maybe someone should google what rigging
means
so that we can get an actual definition
well there's two different ways to look
at it you can rig something
and that means literally to just make
something do a thing you want and then
rigging a competition or a game
means to ensure a favorable outcome
typically or to ensure an outcome period
okay my understanding was the middle of
those three
i always thought that was it was just
where basically you were ensuring that
one person wins or
whatever or whatever the context is the
official uh definition of rig
the first one is make a sailing ship or
boat ready for sailing by providing
yellowstone that's not what we're just
preparing a boat for
for readiness um noted that's all that's
the verb
manage or conduct something fraudulently
so as to produce a result or situation
that is advantageous to a particular
person
where'd you get that done google cause
an artificial rise or fallen prices so i
think it's
fair to say that they weren't saying it
was rigged because the time magazine
article did not imply fraud
and that's why i was very careful with
my words that they didn't say it was
rigged it was fortified
but i think to a certain degree
colloquial understanding is
if you've changed the voting laws
outside
of the state legislat state legislature
in violation of the elector's clause of
the constitution
a lot of people will view that as
fraudulent not as a voter fraud or
election fraud or anything
but as unconstitutional actions that
violate
the supreme law of the land our
constitutions so it's an interesting
legal argument
some people might argue there was one
comment on my tweet where they said
could be misleading because some may
view this as
clearly not rigging just protecting
election integrity while others may
claim that these were outside the
electors clause and thus
a violation and so until it's
adjudicated it could go either way
that's a fair point so the question of
whether or not
this time magazine is saying the
election was rigged is an opinion
on the definition of a word semantics
but i'll tell you this the tribalists
will take
whatever they can get right the trump
supporters are going to say no that
clearly means it was rigged
and the and the biden people and
anti-trump people can say he won fair
and square
they were just protecting voter
integrity what i'm taking from this
entire conversation besides
your point about the correction that was
made is that that second article the way
that that person structured
what they were saying about what you
said and time and everything is how
writers should go about writing articles
you should give all the context well
that was really important because
adding in that your response was to the
time article
was crucial in people understanding
actually what was said and who said it
and when and why and how and whatever
else
and this is what journalists do the
pointer or failed to do rather
because they they don't do that that
often kind of on purpose yeah
manipulation
so listen the way that pointer wrote
my wrote this opening sentence was
crafted lee in a legal way
so i personally did not say the election
was rigged
what they wrote was in a in a post from
controversial youtuber tim poole
comma that stated the election was
rigged so they said in a post
and the post said so now they can make
an argument that the post set has the
words the election was rigged in it
therefore it must be true
you know our statement is a fact i still
think
there's grounds for a false statement
effect because the post actually says
they didn't rig it the full post
literally because they didn't rig it
but you can see how they're trying to
skirt around the truth
in such a way the full context if
someone was actually reading it they
would say
tim poole made a reference to a time
magazine article about a cabal of
wealthy elites
what was his intentions we don't know we
can't read his mind
pointer institute cut all the context
out
they cut out the context of the time
magazine article itself they said
the actual article was just talking
about protecting voter integrity but
that was left out of the tweet
i'm like no it wasn't i quite literally
said they were fortifying the election
by changing the rules that's a quote
from the article
you can read the full article i couldn't
fit it into it into a tweet journalists
do this on purpose
they misshape sentences they manipulate
sentences
they frame things in such a way to make
you believe something
that may or may not be true it i just
had this this it's so crazy that we live
in a world where you can send out a
tweet
where you can just type a paragraph that
gets so much traction
and human focus and can alter
the dialogue of the world of the earth
in like
for months i got an idea i'm gonna buy a
boat
and i'm gonna name it the election and
then
rig it together we'll rig it together
yeah all right and then you can
create the election you can tweet i can
personally state as a statement of fact
that i rigged the election
and then i'm gonna steal it yeah do it
no no but think about how funny it would
be
if you came out on twitter and you were
like i can't confirm i rigged the i
rated the election and tim poole was
involved
yeah yeah and then people are going to
be like what was the second thing
there's a picture of him
the election on it luke stole the
election see that's that's that's
awesome you gotta call it the election
call the boat the election election
yeah the election the 2020 election
that's the name of the boat
okay and then then and then when they
write
that you were that you posted fake news
or whatever or you can say
that i know for a fact that the election
got rigged and they'll be like ah see
he's lying
you then post a picture of the boat and
be like it is a true statement at the
very least we got a photo shoot take it
to court
no but a judge is gonna be like get out
of here you know what you did
yeah my brother once took a picture of
himself holding a big bundle of sticks
and he says hey look at this huge
oh my gosh because he was a wheel yeah
because he was making a point about
the use of words and everything i don't
know if he ever actually i think he
posted on twitter
are you allowed to say that word in that
context or is it always offensive no
because the out the computers don't know
so i'll tell you uh keemstar had this
happen to him oh yeah
where he said there's there is a type of
job i guess you call it
the letter e dash
girl i spaced it out perfectly on pur
i spaced it out on purpose because they
the the youtube algorithm thought that
word when he said it
was actually the n word and so in his
subtitles
it shows a version of the n-word
and he got demonetized because of it
amazing and he was like i didn't say
that word
he said e dash girl
how did they but how it's youtube ai
artists listen listen listen
up and then transcribes it that word
starts with a vowel
so you would say an oh yeah
oh and announce and that's how you
pronounce it i mean youtube's saying it
really fast
yeah youtube's ai just took down uh a
chess player for
having white players and black players
mentioning it too many times but they
did that to him before i'm pretty sure
it's not the first time it's happened
wasn't it because also he was using
terms to like
threat and white and black but that's
normal that's normal it's chess
it's just christ a while back an
australian on an australian network a
radio network someone suggested that
is it racist because white pieces move
first in chess
definitely they've is that like an
ancient
moorish european conflict surely there's
a reason why
i don't think there's any real real
thought behind the colors
especially because the game was being
played among europeans it was literally
just
the different color pieces colors yeah
yeah
what's happening red blue well but no
but red and green i think
sometimes like this is what i'm saying
before we i was saying this just before
you know how i'm the dumbest smart per
smartest dumb person i know there you go
i'm not clever
you could just say you know the black
pieces go first
if you want to yeah yeah but they
decided to make it the queen is on her
own color
is that like a gender thing what about
no
the woman is the power behind the man i
think that's what that that that so are
you saying it's matriarchal then trust
is the matriarchal
society i got it let's make all of the
pieces pawns
oh yeah perfect boom checkers they go
communist
they'll be different from checkers but
communism yep there you go
those socialists finally get what they
want everything is equal the commies get
what they want everything is equal
and no one has any gender and everything
is just the same
perfect that's you know what's really
funny you ever watch the fairly odd
parents
yes you've seen the episode where uh i
think he wished everybody was the same
so that nobody would be bullied
and then everyone was a grey blob but
they still found a way to bully people
like even though they were all now grey
blobs and it was like a really amazing
point for like a kids show to tell
people that no matter what you do
people are will will still find a way to
be nasty and mean to you
and now here we are in this world where
apparently nobody got the message and
they're like everybody should be
genderless and shaved heads like oh you
know it's like the south park episode
where the the future people come and
they're all bald olive colored skin
people who speak a mix of every language
the only thing that southpaw got wrong
was that oh no they got this right too
the genders were identical yeah the
people all looked the exact same that's
really interesting yeah but it won't
stop
oppression because some people sleep on
the top bunk and some people sleep on
the bottom bunk in gravity
like if you spill your cup and the guy's
down below you so you
your highness is going to be all you
know have the advantage
your highness but that's why you just
sleep in the pod
all right all right let's uh let's jump
to super chats everybody if you have not
already
send us your super chats i'll try to
read as many as i can but also smash
that like button subscribe to the
notification bell and check out
timcast.com for exclusive
members only content and uh you know
when we have issues with with
full episodes we will upload them
exclusively to the website
because look a lot of people don't like
hearing it but youtube has already given
us a warning on one of our episodes
and if we get another strike for any
reason that means the show's off for a
whole week and then we'll
if that happened we'd still do the show
we just stream it somewhere else but
that's
still really bad and we want to avoid
that that also means
if there are things we want to talk
about it's going to be at timcast.com
because we're just trying to make sure
we're navigating everything properly
i don't want to sacrifice the entire
channel and my ability to produce
content because it would shut down my
other channels as well
because one person said something and we
can move it over or something like that
so
that keep that in mind we're doing our
best but uh smash the like button
let's read some of these super chats
padre mortalis says
tim used gorilla glue on his beanie
confirmed yep
okay that is not confirmed
you said it deplorable pirate captain
gunbeard says
a question for progressives if only
white people can be oppressive
is it immoral for a person of color to
own white slaves
oh it's interesting about so the the
isn't there like i don't exactly know
this the correlation but slav
and slave root word yeah yeah
do you know anything about the history
of like who enslaved the slavs was it
that was it the turks like the ottoman
empire
uh i'm i don't know but i'm taking the
privilege of knowing so but
again europe is just a whole bloody
territory of conquerors and conquest you
look at what julius caesar did to the
celtics my goodness there's
i mean history is pretty much people
stabbing each other and killing each
other when you look at it at the context
of europe
so there's and then and then in in roman
times
slaves were pretty much uh money
they were valued and during big
conquests
they would make sure to keep people
alive to sell them later because that
was pretty much
a currency so slaves and slavic people
were their own kind of currency
uh the celts uh you know were often
traded by the romans when they were
conquered by julius caesar and a lot of
them i mean they they're
the celts had people in portugal and
poland
in in some places as far as turkey so uh
we have a long history of of murder of
conquest
and slavery all in that region jeez yeah
we have a whole bunch of super chats
where people are just screaming sydney
stephen a says sydney i love your
channel it's cool to see you on tim's
show you rock
huh jake says yay sydney she's my
favorite strange aussie
jessica uh jessica says so glad to see
sydney on the show her comedy skits
always make me laugh yes
i love when that people think i'm funny
that's the best thing honestly because i
just sometimes i watch my content back
and i'm like
okay what's your skit to politics ratio
um i would say
30 stupid and 70 politics
but i'm introducing characters i have
the most disgusting wigs it's just
dreadful
oh i want to get wigs how am i an adult
it's bad you actually yeah i mean like
hey
well that's that's your thing there you
go
let's do it rainbow ones daniel welch
says ian the fake
heme is made from genetically modified
bacteria and has been rushed through
testing for safety
big industry money influence wow yikes
and christoph says fourth time the charm
fingers crossed
with how much you talk about veganism
you should have james wilkes on
worked on the game changers mma fighter
and trains us military
yeah that sounds cool i like talking
food health
veganism and all that stuff that's great
jordan fowler says will you upload
friday's show please and thank you
it is on all podcast platforms and we're
gonna put it on timcast.com
and we will put it up for free for
everybody i think we have the ability to
do that now and so we will try our best
we'll do that later tonight we'll try tj
pollock says hey
tim you're uh hey tim just your average
everyday fedex driver
question about magic do you guys play
commander and if so who you guys play
as commander i quit magic i'm done yeah
i played urza and
beat the hell out of tim so he stopped
actually i played urzah first
you did and i had like stasis it was so
brutal winter's orb
and everybody was like dude nobody wants
to play you anymore
okay i'm not gonna play anymore
and then i switched to some lower
powered commanders and then ian was like
now i'm going to destroy you all and i
was like dude this is not funny yeah i'm
not going to lose
no magic magic's not fun anymore because
it's just rich man wins we've talked
about that have you played magic
i have no idea what you're talking about
magic the gathering it's a card game
oh no like like a literal like in person
yeah yeah
i mean it's online what's the objective
is it a beat tim um there's each player
has 20 lines everyone in the world
and you play creatures and spells to
attack your opponent like yu-gi-oh
yeah yeah was a predecessor came after
magic
okay chess and poker combined i knew a
thing it's awesome
chess and poker and it's kind of like
which not witchcraft but has like
ancient
traditions of magics like black magic
and white magic but that's racist green
magic
aren't
landon says i literally ran to my phone
from across the warehouse i work in when
i heard sydney was on
based bad dad jokes and beautiful to
boot she's the best
oh there you go yes oh my god
parallel knight says sydney how did you
become a citizen of the us from
australia it's my dream to move to us
from uk and collect historical firearms
any info would be very helpful thanks
everyone free the code go ian
so um well i cheated the system because
my mum
is a u.s citizen so me getting
citizenship was just by virtue of being
born and being a human being
that was born to a yank so um i think
that there's a
honestly i've had a couple friends
who've wanted to become citizens and i
think it's a very complicated process as
far as my understanding goes
and i think that there's a bunch of
different visas you can start off with
but
i think you either have to get sponsored
or you have to i want guys correct me if
you know any information about this
because i
i frankly am not an expert because i
mean like you guys i was just born
as a citizen but i think it's just the
visas are really difficult to get
that's my understanding in the very
least you need a you need to apply
online to go to australia if you're an
american
yeah you do it's because it's like you
guys made it hard for us and for the
brits as well and so we made it really
hard back
because i covered no no just generally
like if um
if anybody ever wants to move to
australia you can get a two-year visa
like that
well if you're under 30 you can i don't
know what it's like when you're over 30
but
moving between commonwealth countries is
easy there's a ton of super chats where
they're like sydney yay
that's so cute i love that felix antoine
morin says hi from quebec your show
helped me stay awake and not become woke
i'm in elementary i'm i'm in elementary
school and i fight wokeness on the
ground by showing children stoicism and
jbp wisdom
you're an entire elementary school
that's impressive uh i'm kidding
but uh yeah jordan peterson's awesome
stoicism is great too
3d pyromaniac says amen tim i don't
remember exactly what that was from but
i appreciate it rylo says watson's
mixed accent reminds me of how i got my
accent southern
our ancestors never fully kicked the
accents of the old countries very cool
oh well at least someone appreciates it
thank you it's going to be really
interesting when you get a mix of like
standard non-regional american southern
texan
and australian all mixed together oh my
god it's going to be
even now like sometimes i accidentally
i'm not trying to be like a doodle head
about it and like i'm trying do you see
how hard i'm trying not to swear yeah
man you really got me an advice
you were like oh i don't swear i never
swear it comes out sometimes because i
hang out with elijah so much and when
you know we get going it's just and i
swear a lot
like a lot i don't swear on my channel
at all but i swear a lot in everyday
life and i feel like it's just an aussie
thing it's every other word i'm just
shattering the illusion now people are
like oh my god
my understanding is that the c word in
australia is more like saying buddy
yeah yeah i mean it depends it depends
which kind of aussies you ask but most
aussies would just be like yeah what's
up
see you next tuesday um no what was i
talking about i've completely lost my
train of thought
your accent accent yes so when it ends
up being i accidentally say y'all and i
go
sydney no no darling you're not from
this place
do not stop that i say y'all all the
time but that's because mike
you're an american though it's okay my
dad's from waco
and so i grew up with him saying it all
the time and i just i like it
it sounds cute it's cute i like when
people say you all it's a good word yeah
it's easy yeah does he say use not not a
fan
yes not into that use guys that's uh
that's a brooklyn thing isn't it no
use use use guys yinz apparently is a
thing actually you know what i'm gonna
call you out ian you said cran before
it's crayon crayon crayon
k-r-a-n keep me honest some wax crayons
i didn't know this was a thing until
recently christmas you disgusting i'm a
northeast ohioan
all right hey puffy says tim's
description of sweden's race swedish
racist sound exactly like the
description for democrats lol
yeah yeah yeah sounds about right
julian powell says luke don't ever
mention bill cosby again
you have hardly researched the details
of those cases and hannibal burris he
was propped up by hollywood oh smackdown
oh snap you got challenged you're
entitled to your opinion send me some
evidence to the contrary i'd love to
hear it uh twitter.com
forward slash luke we are change send me
what you got that could change my mind
yeah send me what you got
that's right david eriman says love
sydney's content
tim i recommend a topic and guests
normally not allowed i know
you shunhead and sydney for a center
left and right discussion on men's
rights and
feminism's impact on culture and society
shu
is always welcome to come on the show i
will say
it's like pulling teeth to get leftists
to come on they're
they there's just a million and one
excuses for every single time they've
ever been invited as to why they can't
do it i'll say this much if shoe
i don't know if you and shoe know each
other if you and june are friends i used
to love her content
she's part of the reason why you used to
yeah you used to do
words no i think i i i have her muted on
twitter but i
wow even more fighting words no i i
really i think she's so funny
and i think her sense of humor is
brilliant but no i would
you know what i'd for sure do it june i
we've never spoken but
i once sent you an email i don't think
she'll do it no well i'm just saying you
know everyone go harass her
the the no no no no no not harass
harassers and like go say
love the two no but i don't i don't
listen to encouragement
there we go the problem with the the
left is there's two vicious
like don't get me wrong you've got
viciousness would be vicious no not her
yeah because that she would get
eviscerated oh yeah i mean like
sure sure she tweeted something about uh
it was really funny it was like
remembering like november 22nd or
something and it said like bernie
sanders was winning the primary
and the next image is like a crying pepe
or whatever
and then i responded with that time
magazine article said they started this
effort in the fall of 2019
these are high-profile democrats and
media conglomerates
fortifying the election before the
primary and then we know what happened
with iowa where bernie like the results
like never came in i guess there's this
weird app or something
the left has routinely complained that
bernie sanders gets cheated all the time
i tweeted agreeing like look at this
article that said this and then her
followers
attack attack attack i tweeted to hassan
uh peeker peaker
congrats when he when he broke half a
million subs and his they just go nuts
crapping all over me and so that's
really awful i didn't realize that that
was i thought her
her audience was was mostly people like
you and me
like the us no no no she's like i think
her she's got like auntie woke leftists
for the most part now
there there was yeah why you said you
you said you had her muted on twitter i
assumed you
oh she just posted like there was one
thing i can't remember what it was but
it really
because i don't like blocking people and
i don't i just think it's psycho like
unless you're actually abusing me i'm
not gonna block you i just no
but um i muted her because she just
started saying
things that i was like i don't it was
just stuff that i was like this is like
way out in left field no whereas i'm
like i follow a lot of liberals i do
because i like getting an alternative
viewpoint i think it rounds out my
perspectives a lot
but when people just go they were saying
that she did a camera what it was but it
went over the edge for me and i was like
i'm out
there are a lot of people that used to
be like auntie sjw who have just
basically stopped paying attention and
then just given in to whatever the
narrative is yep
i wonder if uh it was delicious by the
way
me muting her was not it wasn't
malicious like i don't have beef with
her we've never spoken
i wonder if do you know what do you know
what happens
lauren southern and shu no like they've
done videos weren't they friends
they'd done videos together yeah and
then like i guess shu put out a
statement saying she couldn't befriend
lauren southern anymore or something
and then like retracted it or something
like that i don't know a whole lot about
it but i wonder if
you know i i wonder if there are a lot
of people there like
there are people that i literally hung
out with
and have been friends with who started
disparaging me
incorrectly like like being critical on
things that weren't true
are you talking about me no i'm talking
about other other like
anti-sjw youtuber types who have been
like oh well you know i'm gonna
say this about tim and it's like bro you
just made like that's not true like
like i think that there's i think what
happened was there are a lot of people
whose careers are built on youtube
and when they were going after the
anti-sw's
i'm sorry when they were anti-sjw
challenging critical theory and all that
stuff
and they still kind of do but when they
were very heavily into it
hardcore and align with all the keck
memes and everything they were making
money
and then once they started sitting
seeing people get banned for this
and seeing the mainstream go after the
keck flag and those memes
all of a sudden their tunes changed and
their and the videos they put out
changed and the things they weren't
saying was changing
and now many of these people who are
once i don't know like hanging out with
lauren southern
are all of a sudden propping up you know
far leftists and their audience has
totally flipped and stuff
and there's a lot of them who did it
they don't want to get banned they don't
want to lose their income
and you know hey well when it's a
business it's a business i guess yeah i
mean i can respect that not that well
no respect's the wrong word i don't know
the right word but i
get it i get it yeah i can understand it
i guess um but yeah
i i don't i don't want people thinking i
like dislike
june i don't i just there's there's it's
you know
i've invited a ton of leftists
tons if you ever get voshon let me know
we did we had him yeah
yeah yeah props to him he came on yeah
it was great four-hour conversation too
a lot of arguments i love most people
though
and uh you know so so you know props to
him
we disagree a lot of things but uh that
was all right i think
you know i don't necessarily trust
his i don't i don't i don't believe him
and his opinions like you know how do
you why do you think they're
disingenuous or
well how do you praise roving bands of
black clan individuals burning down
black neighborhoods
and then support 25 000 national
guardsmen being in dc
there's no principle there like are you
in favor of like attacking minority
communities
now i understand they might argue that's
hyperbolic of me to say
no no literally like in atlanta when
that rapper was a big mike came out and
said please stop burning down
my business my neighborhood right like
i'm not saying that he
like vosh directly supported that
specific moment
but just like when i criticized the
police
heavily it was because they were
destroying the working class when i
criticized antifa and black lives matter
riots is because they were destroying
the working class
when i criticized 25 000 troops in dc
it's because it's literally an
authoritarian lockdown
it's always my opinion is always about
like the working individuals the freedom
and the rights of the people
people like vosh and this is just my
opinion he's allowed to disagree and
maybe he'll say i'm incorrect
but he comes out and it's like his
position is supporting supporting antifa
but like bro
they burned down a black firefighter's
bar in minneapolis
like are you gonna come out and condemn
that no you're gonna
you're gonna defend the actions of these
people probably maybe even calling out
individually but i think they should be
wholly condemned for doing this and not
protected
and then when i tweeted something like
you know
dc is under lockdown vosh tweeted at me
well
is there a reason you think that may be
the case and i was like bro i just
tweeted in support of rashida tulabe
a leftist when she said do not allow the
government to expand their security
powers over this and he's like well
there's you know a reason for it
i'm like no there's no context in which
i'm going to support 25 000
federal troops locking down our nation's
capital sorry i'm not an authoritarian
so anyway i digress there's a lot of
people who claim to be leftists but they
can't sit in hot seat
they won't do it they'll make a better
excuse in the book they'll oh covet
oh i can't do it i'm like vosh was here
he had no issues he didn't get sick or
anything like we have hand sanitizer we
clean the whole place we take care of
that
i think the reality is most
conservatives
are uh not not all definitely not all
but i would say most conservatives truly
believe what they're saying
yeah the leftists who are willing to
come on a show like this believe what
they're saying
and are brave there are a lot of
leftists who probably believe what
they're saying but are scared of getting
eviscerated by by the cult or the
collective
because they will and cancel culture is
brutal
conservatives have their version of
cancer culture for sure but they're
much more tolerant of people who
disagree with them maybe it's because
they've grown up being used to people
saying
you suck and you're bad you know what i
mean racism so i'll say this
i i will paint with a broad brush a lot
of these anti-sjw youtubers who have
gone left
as cowards who have simply changed their
actual opinions in order to stay
safe and maintain some kind of career
that's really what i think
i think you know you see what they say
you see who they disavow
you see how their opinions change and
it's like oh that's just so convenient
for you isn't it
maintaining your business and then
meanwhile their fans call other people
grifters
i know they love that word don't they
yeah
anyway let's uh let's keep reading just
a lot of tweets you know
uh sydney and tim on one show it must be
my birthday i love what you both do so
much well great we should definitely
have you on more i suppose
daft punk broke up that says and cable
said you guys hear that no
no they didn't just break up one of them
exploded whoa
so they did a video where one of the
dudes
triggers the self-destruct on the other
dude he walks away and then explodes
and they're like that's it def punk's
over yeah they're done what's that
animated movie they did
and if you haven't seen it you've got to
see it it's amazing it's like an
hour long in a movie yeah it's all music
and it's like this animated uh it's like
interstellar 25 25 or 22
22 maybe tim you got to see it it's
awesome yeah
hawk says it is so disheartening to have
discussion with my woke lefty friends
it seems like i have to unpack 10
concepts to get them to see my point of
view
even still they don't get how damaging
the woke ideology is in practice
let's play a game you're a conservative
right do you
how do you feel about universal
healthcare okay no don't ask me these
questions because i'm australian
so no this is this is great and this is
this this is one of the reasons
i don't fit neatly into the conservative
okay right right yeah i also like
between libertarian and conservative
okay
i don't think universal health care in
the american sense is
good but i think that some i've never
said this publicly
um some sense of uh socialized health
care is not a bad idea in my opinion
like the australian
bad idea the australian system is good
so like in my opinion but also we have
you know 14 times less the population
size or 15 times less but we have
affordable private health insurance
which i have but if i get really sick
and i
have to go to the hospital for whatever
reason it doesn't cost me an arm and a
leg and i don't have to sell my kidney
i went to the hospital emergency room
and it was
an overnight stay in 2014 for a kidney
stone and the bill was i think
what was it like sixteen thousand
dollars that's right six like one
six like zero yeah and then when i when
i called them and said
it was actually right after i left
device and before i started fusion so i
had a gap
then i said oh oh uh it's 4 500. it like
dropped way down actually no no i think
i i can't remember i talked about this
before it may have dropped down to 16.
i think it dropped down to six i think
it was like 40 or something thousand i'm
not sure
insanely high insane overnight stay
painkillers drugs
cat scans x-rays trying to figure out
the problem was super expensive
superintendents so i'm in favor of like
basic coverage you break your arm you
get your arms out you get the flu you
get tamiflu you go to the hospital and
make sure you don't die
but you need some kind of private
supplemental for more extreme and more
expensive
you know right and like elective
surgeries and things like that sure yes
you know i don't like um when people
like chronic
health care problems covering those
because if someone eats
crap and like refuses to stop eating
sugar and they get really sick i'm not
gonna pay for that
i refuse to pay for their idiocy it's up
to you to take care of your own body if
they fall down and break their arm i'm
happy to cover it what about someone
who's and this is not because i have a
vested interest in this i'm actually
just curious what about someone who's
got an illness that is completely has
nothing to do with anything they've
ever done in their life they've been
healthy and they just end up getting
diabetes because they would have got a
virus do you ever see total recall
yes what if like that dude that's
growing out of their chest like a total
recall
yeah i guess if it's not diet oriented
if it's something that they have no
control over then maybe yeah we should
take care of it but that's a really good
point
i'm just curious there's an issue of
america a lot of sedentary people a lot
of out of shape unhealthy industries 60
percent obesity
in the u.s right so we're doing it
that's that is a big problem i'll
we'll be paying heavily for people
having experience and then it will
encourage them to not stop that's the
problem
yeah well yeah i guess that's because
you don't want to pay well i guess the
thing here is you don't want to pay for
other people's lifestyle choices right
that's what it is definitely not so
that's why i think there's like a
i don't know if it's a libertarian
argument but it's one that's like if you
want to do drugs
go for your life like you want to do the
thing cool but
in 20 years when you have like you're
you know you've got no veins left and
you've got your heart
night exactly you know your your heart
is not working your body is shutting
down
don't expect me to pay for it and i
think that's not a bad idea the reason i
asked is
that we have no discernible way to
determine what is conservative or
liberal right there's there's no like
vosh came here and he said that i was
far right
you're far right he said i was fighting
i know it's funny
i'm like i literally did a documentary
on systemic and institutional racism
have argued with trump supporters about
the existence of such things
and they're like you're far right i
tweeted uh it was really funny i tweeted
i actually like jacobin the magazine
because they have an article they
actually have several defending free
speech and so i was like hey look i
don't agree with them on their politics
their economic values
but like they're standing up for the
principle of free speech for the right
reasons and i respect them for doing it
people who are willing to like we can
disagree on polit on policy and stuff
but if we agree on freedom and and the
reason we need it well i'm good go for
do your thing
and then someone responded it's you're a
leftist it makes sense and i'm like i
love it
to the conservatives i'm a leftist like
up there like obviously and then to the
leftists i'm far right
so it's just like you're kind of
politically homeless aren't you but you
don't really fit neatly into
yeah centrist i don't know though like i
don't know if centrist really exists
today i mean because of
hyperpolarization it doesn't
yeah because i would i would classify
you as like center left
yeah oh yeah definitely that's yeah i've
always been center left libertarian
but i've always thought that i'm center
right and people are always like why are
you so far right why are you so right
wing and i'm like
what what about you is like far right
nothing absolutely
nothing what makes you center right what
do you feel like how do you
because i think that i even though
people do i try really hard to see
things from even though i don't agree
with the liberal perspective
most of the time because i do have i am
australian i've grown up in a country
that's not like hard
right you know it's australian
conservatism is very different to
american conservatives in my humble
opinion
because your conservatives are still
pretty leftist right yeah i mean like
there's some
there's some so for example australia is
not a chris well
some people are christian australia but
for the most part and some of you would
disagree with me on this
a lot of aussies are not christian and
they don't have any sort of religious
bent or if they are a christian they're
not practicing
my grandma who is a hardcore catholic
once described australia as a godless
nation which
i mean i don't know i don't know how
wrong she is because a lot of people
just don't have belief which is
fine whatever um you know a lot of
aussies are a pro
choice so that's another big thing a lot
of people would be like oh my god can't
believe it but that's like a really
common perspective to have is just to be
like yep cool i'm fine with this
i think it's very simple are you woke or
anti-woke
i think that's a way better way of
looking at things honestly and then yeah
it's really funny because you get these
progressives who thought it was better
to prop up joe biden
than donald trump because biden was weak
i guess and he might give them some of
what they want
and my opinion was it was better to prop
up donald trump because he was more
disruptive to the establishment
and was doing better for working-class
people than than biden was no new wars
was a good thing not like trump was
perfect
and so was like is that the only real
divide because on policy
i actually will like sit down with some
of these like progressive channels and
be like oh i agree yeah i agree on that
like we had destiny
on the show and we agreed on a ton of
stuff and he but he's actually super
woke so i think that defines it i guess
i guess i guess the thing is to be on
the left you have to never challenge the
left which is why leftists
won't come on the show they're scared
and i'm not saying it to be mean or
going to rise out of them
they genuinely are like i will get
attacked by the left
i'm willing to call them out and say not
these people are nuts they aren't
because they don't want to attack they
don't want to risk their bread and
butter
yeah well i mean i guess that i think
that's why i'm happy to be on this side
of things
you know yeah people actually are open
to yeah freed uh funny about that yeah
collectivism versus individualism
thinking for yourself very important all
right let's read some more we got larry
rego says i just want you to say my name
i'm drunk drunk and barbecuing keep it
the good work my man will do that was
awesome
daniel welch says can't wait for the
members only section where sydney can do
us aussies proud by showing
we are the most foul-mouthed country on
earth it's going to be great
about isn't it man we actually went way
too long in the super chats i got to
read some more
student of history says idea for a new
law the reaffirmation of the supremacy
of the constitution and amendments
across the u.s
with fatty fines for and government
group or persons violating these laws
and yes tim cast crew government stamps
your rights and people say yes daddy
see i told you it's a thing it's
definitely a thing dj
mederos says genghis khan is it's chiang
kai-shek
genghis empire exterminated 11 of the
world's existing population at the time
of their empire
yikes man he killed too many people jeez
but he let them keep their religions
there you go he left them alive yes
daniel irving says tim
please hire sydney if she's willing been
watching her channel for a couple of
years she's a perfect fit for tim cast
irl
great they want you to stay on the show
there you go tim
come on hot commodity right here njb
football says hey tim this is my first
super chat
if you want to mimic a new zealand
accent listen to clone troopers in the
star wars episodes two and three
i know they say text yeah yeah when you
send someone a text
so your x your e sounds xd you have to
say
sucks for six so they say sucks sucks
yup sucks he sucks is 66.
are you doing a new zealand accent i
cannot because i don't i don't sound
like i have a mouth full of sand
so yes how is that what you say is that
that sound
no i i apologize to the kiwis but i uh
the the the hardcore kiwi accent i'm
like
mary accent's kind of cool is that where
kiwis are from
kiwi fruits no they're from china oh
kiwi birds are from new zealand they're
from new zealand yeah yeah
because they look like very cute they're
very cute the civic nationalist says the
queen is the head of state of all
members of the commonwealth she has the
power to dissolve parliament
please read more about the monarchy if
you're going to criticize my country
get someone who actually does know this
stuff on if you do want to talk about
monarchy how dare you insult the queen
i would love to have a monarch i love
the queen though just someone that knows
everything about it
yeah not a monarchist maybe a monarchy
expert like a monarchist is different
like pro monarchy i don't really care
where their pro or con lies i just want
the knowledge
you know the the arg there i had a
conversation with some lefties a long
time ago
where i said that authoritarianism is
more efficient
than collectivism and they disagreed and
i was like listen i didn't say it was
good
i said that when the soviets snapped
their fingers to build something it was
built
not well though efficient doesn't mean i
i'm not saying it was going to work
i'm saying that they could say go do
this now
in a free system in a free market system
guiding
you know trying to get something done is
often very difficult incentives tax
incentives weird regulation it ends up
becoming just some kind of
command economy we have a whole bunch of
super chats from everybody saying
that uh you know sydney is great glad to
see her on the show so i'm just going to
skip over all these ones and uh
jump down as you do a couple more well i
collectively love all the people who
said nice things
mickey stone says victorian here five
thousand dollar fines aren't worth going
further than five kilometers away from
your home
our police force is the bigger issue
they just do whatever the government
says
also everyone in the suburbs hates
melbourne city and inner suburb folk
yeah it's so true no it is so true i so
i grew up
in one of the last suburbs like of
melbourne before it becomes victoria
and yeah like people are just anti
the city folk because they just aren't
they're it's just different it's
different i'm not i'm not gonna say
anything negative about them but it's
just different
but the police yes they act like attack
dogs for the victorian government and it
is revolting
totally revolting you want to talk about
police brutality
like we should when you can swear in the
bonus segment over at timcast.com
we have a question for luke from drew p
weiner is infowars alex jones owned by
time warner and ted turner
what do you make of the video of a cop
asking an infowars employee who he works
for
um i haven't seen that video send it to
me luke we are change
i don't think uh you know aj works for
ted turner or
cnn uh there's a lot of negative things
said about ted turner and cnn by alex
jones
so uh i i haven't seen it but if you
have any evidence
what was his name again p weiner p
weiner p weiner droopy weiner if you
have some evidence i would love to see
it
uh luke we are changed twitter i feel
like i'm on the simpsons brandon
mcgregor says not all aussies are happy
with other aussies being like
okay daddy government but then again i'm
an aussie that is not a descendant of
convicts so maybe that has something to
do with it
also great to see sydney here oh yeah i
totally acknowledge that that's why i
want to make the point some aussies are
like daddy
government but a lot of them i think
like i do and they're based and i love
them
because they are criminals yeah because
uh well apparently our friend here is
not a crim
a crim is that what you guys say yeah do
you guys like
you you like find out this guy you've
been dating is actually a crim and
you're like
oh no yeah secret tribes of the
descendants of the
comments yeah we're all separated out
into our little segregation groups you
got us
exactly grant thompson says slave comes
from the french word
esclave of the same term escalate comes
from the latin word esclava which is the
latin word for that term as well as the
latin word
for slav slavs were the predominant
slaves of europe
oh interesting where's my reparations
nova nova zero says hey sydney you want
to start saying yeah nah
to see to these see uh your new mates
yeah nah yeah um that's actually a thing
we do say that
yeah for you kevin sear says ian you get
my very first super chat
sometimes when you open your mouth it's
like nails on a chalkboard but dang
dang it i love that shirt reminds me of
david tennant's
david tennant's doctor on doctor who you
keep being you
i'd love i'd love to get like one of
those uh time warp
machine things did that burn your ears
dude
what was that guy's name thanks for the
super chat by the way no that was nice
cyan davey says my other super chat
didn't seem to go through properly but i
was saying that australia isn't the
weak-minded country of weak individuals
many are saying
most of us just want to be left alone to
do what we want
yeah that's what everybody kind of wants
but when you do that the bad people take
over
that's true patriot american says tim
are you planning on having kyle kashev
on the show anytime soon also sydney
love you in your videos
um no but we could definitely kyle's
cool we'd love to have them on the show
that'd be great
talk about guns and other stuff
uh let's see let's maybe do uh one more
mad russian says sydney why do you call
yourself a vampire lord
okay so back in the day probably about
probably about a decade ago i used to
make videos music videos where i'd like
playing play piano and sing because
that's the thing
that i used to do and a couple people
found the
channel that i have that is still up on
youtube i think that has two videos on
it
and they were like oh you haven't aged
in 10 years so
you must be a vampire and i was like yep
definitely a vampire i can't remember
where the lord thing came from it's just
when people say stupid things to me that
i just
i'm like oh cool guys here's my new name
well it just means you're in charge of
the vampires
exactly i am the vampire lord i mean
like
that's that's your widow's peak yeah
exactly all right
it's a hardcore one too let's see c4
mcburger's workshop i'm probably
pronouncing that wrong says i'm a kiwi
and we don't speak like that and you're
blaspheming
uh i interviewed that guy gareth morgan
and his wife because they rode their
motorcycles through north and south
korea that's so cool
yeah it's crazy stuff cool story uh
anyway my friends smash that like button
and if you haven't already go to
timcast.com become a member because
we're going to have a
profendi laden segment with uh sydney
coming up in about an hour or so where
we'll continue the conversation
and you can follow me on in you can
follow me on instagram
parlor and minds and i i guess twitter i
will you know i hate promoting these big
platforms but
that's the reality at tim cast my other
youtube channels are youtube.comcast
youtube.comcastnews this show is live
monday to friday 8pm
so if you're listening on the podcast
platform or whatever leave us a good
comment give us all the stars all of
them five whatever how many they tell
you to give
give us a thumbs up subscribe share the
notification bell
share this podcast with your friends
because it's the best way to actually
promote it we really appreciate it
you want to shout out anything sydney oh
no just you know what
i because youtube has started uh age
restricting and deleting my content
have they really yeah it's it's really
upsetting i wake up till like this is
age restricted this i'm like okay cool
this is great
um got you got my first uh warning and
all that sort of stuff happening so it's
good welcome to the club yeah i feel
like i'm part of a really like a really
small cool group of people now no but um
my biggest thing at the moment is
because i don't know how long my channel
is going to be around uh if you do want
to go and follow my channel people are
welcome to obviously at sydney watson
it's very all straightforward
but my website i would love people to go
and subscribe to my email list because
then i can send them cute emails about
things i'm doing oh there you go there
you go i'm just yeah i'm like you i like
i don't want to promote like the big
social medias because it's like
they're just they just hate us and yeah
you never know how long you're going to
be around for before they're just like
yep
that's it get out so that's exactly what
i've been doing also on we are
change.org top right hand corner you
could put in your email and you could
guarantee my safety
from of course the big tech oligarchs
that of course uh
we haven't been having the best of
relationship as of with
for a very long time also the shirt i'm
wearing right now
says you had me at f the system if you
like it and you want it you could get it
on
the best political shirts dot com
thebestpoliticalshirts.com
thanks again for having me you can also
follow me at uh ian crossland.net for
all my social medias and if you'd like
to pick up a mug
or some other piece of merchandise like
this one that says free the code
something i want to do in the future
free some software code from these big
tech organizations to uh
dispense with this monopolistic force uh
thanks for following sydney thanks for
being here and leave a comment on this
video if you liked it because it's about
to go up on youtube where you can
comment
yes indeed and i am sour patch lids on
twitter i am sour patchlets also on
mines real sourpatch
lids on instagram that is where you can
watch my little post show chats i go
home and i make tea
and i talk about the things that i think
about and i think about a lot of
philosophy so if you are interested in
that kind of thing
follow me over there on my instagram
real sour patch lids
we get one last super chat cause this
one just came in michael holder says
check out the latest vosh destiny debate
lots of crazy to dig through but the
main takeaway is that vosh is not on
vosh not only literally doesn't have
principles but believes no one has
principles
dude's legit nuts destiny looked like
the pope in comparison
with that being said let's uh let's jump
to the timcast.com
members only bonus segment coming up and
hopefully just about an hour or so
go to timcast.com and we will see you
all there thanks for hanging out bye
guys
you